Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritler und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe Nummer sechzig vom zwölften.
Zwölften Februar.
Zwanzig einundzwanzig, Freitag der zwölfte, ihr merkt schon, heute gibt's gute Nachrichten, denn äh ja, Freitag heißt Corona Weekly und das heißt Pavel ist dabei, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und wie es hier Usos ist, seit fast einem Jahr wollen wir hier mal äh zusammenfegen, was sich so in dieser Woche an Zahlen und Erkenntnissen,
gefunden hat, was für an sonstigen
interessanten Fundstücken aus dem Netz haben, kratzen können und äh ja, was sonst noch so erwähnenswert ist. Wir hatten wieder eine schöne Feedbackrunde im Clubhaus am Dienstag, die,
sehr lang gedauert hat. Ich glaube, das waren fast vier Stunden,
ne, die wir da rumängen, aber war einfach äh interessant, es ist äh sehr gut mit euch dann auch mal da direkt ins Gespräch zu kommen und Fragen nochmal zu klären und Sachen zu debattieren.
Ja, da können wir euch nur ermuntern. Wir werden das dann am nächsten Dienstag, dann ähm Dienstagabend, einundzwanzig Uhr wieder machen. Das wäre dann der sechzehnte Februar.
Ja, aber heute gehen wir mal wieder hier äh auf unser Standard äh Programm. Ich würde mal die Sendung mit Feedback beginnen.
Das gab's auch und das mögen wir auch besonders, wenn ihr es in die Kommentare schreibt, da kommt so einiges zusammen, ist manchmal ein bisschen schwierig, da einen Überblick zu bekommen, aber es gib
dann euch auch die Möglich,
mal so halbwegs zusammenhängt, äh, uns hier zu kritisieren, vielleicht eine Sache, die mir noch so nebenbei zugespielt wurde, da wir ja letztes Mal den lustigen Titelzensur, es ein Beitrag zum Infektionsschutz gewählt haben
Ja, das äh ist schon so ein bisschen,
scherzhaft natürlich auch gemeint war, wenn wir natürlich hier nicht zu einem Zensurregime auf ährufen wollten, sondern das Ganze ja nur so einen Spruch war im Kontext von man muss sich über seine mediale Botschaft schon zweimal Gedanken machen,
Der kam da ganz guter gutes Beispiel, wurde mir noch eine gesteckt, nämlich äh wie mittlerweile ja medial mit Sudiziden umgegangen wird.
Das ist interessant, ja.
Ne? Und weil weil da ist ja im Prinzip auch so eine Selbstverpflichtung im medialen Raum, dass wenn jetzt äh Leute sich umbringen,
dass ähm.
Namen nicht genannt werden und äh das auch überhaupt generell sehr zurückhaltend berichtet wird. Weil man einfach über die Zeit gelernt hat.
Was diese mediale Aufmerksamkeit,
einfach dazu äh geführt hat, andere Leute, die da so ein bisschen über sowas nachdenken, dann in ihren äh Beschlüssen noch äh Nahrung zu geben und seitdem man das gelassen hat, sind dann eben auch entsprechende Sudizidzahlen zurückgegangen.
Das ist ein ist in der Tat ja ein guter Punkt.
Ja, fand ich auch. Aber dann gab's auch noch etwas äh konkretere Feedbacks unter anderem zu der Frage mit digitalen Messgeräten bei diesen Schnelltests.
Muss ich zugeben, man macht ja nicht so oft Schwangerschaftstests und äh da äh gibt's diese Technologie schon ein bisschen länger,
Jonas schreibt uns
Ich bin Chemiker und ja, ein Quantenpunkt ist ein üblicher Weise äh einige nanometer großer Partikel, der klein genug ist, dass eine Quantenmechanische Beschreibung der Eigenschaften zutreffender ist, als die üblichen Beschreibungen,
der makroskopischen Welt. Diese Dinger haben deswegen tolle optische Eigenschaften, wegen denen man sie gerne einsetzt.
Hier werden sie wohl die Flurssenz des Farbstoffs verstärken. Klingt toll, ist aber nur so mäßig Hightech. Was der Test also äh nach sehr oberflächlicher Recherche macht, ist dasselbe wie der normale Test nur
dass der Farbstreifen am Ende noch einfach schwarz wird, äh nicht einfach nur schwarz wird, sondern Neonfarben. Der wird dann angeleuchtet, leuchtet in einer anderen Farbe zurück.
Also der typische Effekt, den man vom Schwarzlicht kennt und das kann man dann halt äh messen.
Vorteile sind hier vor allem gutes Marketing für den Hersteller, äh aber eben auch ein eindeutiges Ergebnis bei den normalen Schnelltest ähm,
ist ja nicht nur die Probenentnahme an Problemen, sondern eben auch die Interpretationen des Ergebnisses. Ne, so gehen manche Nutzerinnen davon aus,
wenn der Streifen genauso farbig ist wie der Kontrollstreifen, aber das ist natürlich Blödsinn. Digital sagt einem das Gerät das Ergebnis.
Eventuell können sie weniger Chemikalien verwenden, da der eigentliche Fahrpunkt kleiner sein kann, als der Streifen im Analogentest, je nach Aufwand,
ähm das Zeug herzustellen, können sie so vielleicht mehr Tests machen. Außerdem könnte man das Lesegerät so bauen wie ein Blutzuckermessgerät, dann kann man sich das Gehäuse und die Technik äh kann man die wiederverwenden. So sieht der Test allerdings zum derzeitigen Zeitpunkt.
Nicht aus. Mein Fazit nach überfliegen. Tolles Buzzword Bingo mit eventuellen kleinen Vorteilen, die Nachteile hätten wir ja bereits erwähnt.
Ja das das kam aus verschiedenen Richtungen äh in ähnlicher Form. Das hat Jonas hier ganz gut zusammengefasst.
Bestätigt glaube ich aber auch vor allem die Vermutungen die wir angestellt hatten oder die ich angestellt hatte.
Aber wenn ich so den Eindruck erweckt habe, das wäre jetzt irgendwie der geilste neue Hightech äh der Welt, also so habe ich es gar nicht unbedingt gemeint.
Nee, ähm ich glaube, wir haben das aber auch nicht so dargestellt, aber ja.
Dann noch ein Nachtrag zu dem Thema Masken trocknen.
Von kleiner Nachtrag zu der Wochenmaskenwäscheleine von der Timlets vorletzte Sendung Sprach und Masken wiederzuverwenden. Ähm.
Sollte man nur in Situationen machen, die die Masken eher kaum beanspruchen, besserer Vorschlag, nimmt eine Tageszeitung,
falte diese auf Maskengröße und fächert sie dann auf in jedes Fach aus mehreren Lagenpapier, legt ihr dann eine Tagesmaske, ihr könnt die Fächer auch mit Klebezetteln als Art Kartei
versehen, Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag und so weiter. Wenn ihr meint, die Masken,
können, äh, könnten doch mal komplett erneuert werden, schmeißt er sie mit der Zeitung zusammen,
Generell ist es sinnvoll, Masken gefalteten Papierzeitungen abzulegen und unterwegs in der Bustasche aufzubewahren. Die Trocknungswirkung funktioniert wie beim Schultrocknen mit zerknüllter Zeitung und das potenzielle Virenmaterial versinkt im Papier und flattert nicht durch die Luft,
Bitte hängt euch keine Wäscheleiden, quer durch die Wohnung mit potentiell kontaminierten Masten, außer ihr wohnt in riesigen Häusern, mit riesigen Dachböchböden auf dem Dorf, weit weg, mit viel Querwind lebt ihr in einer Stadtwohnung, lasst es.
Good Point. Ähm das haben wir so nicht bedacht in dem Moment.
Mhm. Das ist ein guter, guter Hinweis. Ich habe äh hm.
Ja, ich hab diese Woche was ausprobiert, ähm, so, was ich dann auch getwittert habe, äh, nämlich auch im Zusammenhang mit,
Masken ähm weil da war also folgende Situation, nämlich ich wollte halt ausrechnen zu sagen ähm den sogenannten Corona Schutzfaktor,
den ich äh jetzt auch erfunden habe. Ähm.
Ja, der Corona-Schutzfaktor, sag mal los.
So wie bei,
sich so ein bisschen vorstellen halt wie bei Sonnencreme. Äh nur äh ja äh dass das halt äh auf Masken gemünzt ist. Das heißt ähm,
mit so einer N fünfundneunzig oder FFP drei Maske habe ich halt so einen Corona Schutzfaktor von zehn ungefähr, das heißt, ich kann mich,
zehn Mal so lange in der riskanten Situation äh aufhalten äh oder habe nun das Zehntel vom Risiko, wenn ich mich gleich lange aufhalte. Das ist schon eine Menge, aber es ist halt nicht ähm.
Es ist halt nicht die Welt, es ist halt auch nicht nichts so F äh und FFP drei ist ungefähr Schutzfaktor vierzig übrigens.
Und in dem Zusammenhang ähm so.
Ähm aber das ist jetzt sozusagen nur für also Schutzfaktor zehn oder dreißig, wenn der andere keine Maske auf hat.
Wenn beide Masken aufhaben, dann kombinieren sich die Schutzfaktoren quasi, aber ähm um wie viel es halt so ein bisschen schwierig zu ermitteln, weil nämlich.
FP Masken.
Werden halt nur auf Dichtigkeit beim Einatmen geprüft, nicht beim Ausatmen, das heißt es gibt keinerlei,
irgendwie Messwerte, wie viel sie denn jetzt tatsächlich äh sagen wie viel beim Ausatmen eigentlich daneben,
geht, so das kann von Maske zu Maske total verschieden sein, weil wie gesagt, wird nicht gemessen. Bei den OP Masken wiederum.
Ist nur zertifiziert, wie viel die beim Ausatmen zurückhalten, ja? Aber nicht beim Einatmen. So, dass es da völlig egal. Das heißt,
da gibt's dann sagen es auch ein bisschen unklar. Ich bin dann über eine Studie äh gestolpert,
die besagte, wenn also beide Leute jetzt OP Masken aufhaben, dann hat man ungefähr so einen Schutzfaktor von dreißig in der Kombination halt, von,
beide medizinische Maske. So und.
Dann dachte ich mir, hm, okay, die eine Maske ist eigentlich fürs Einatmen spezifiziert, die andere ist fürs Ausatmen spezifiziert. Ähm wie werden das, wenn ich einfach mal OP-Maske mit FFP kombiniere.
Und ähm bei den Masken, die ich habe, äh sind aber die OP Masken zu klein, die gibt's auch in großen. Ähm eigentlich wäre wahrscheinlich,
OP Maske über FFP zwei Maske wäre das beste, aber das passt normalerweise nicht. Und dann habe ich das zeitweise nicht passte genau umgekehrt gemacht, habe mir also eine FFP,
zwei Maske über eine OP Maske mal gepackt und geguckt, was denn dann passiert.
Interessante war, also am Atemwiderstand hat sich jetzt nichts geändert, also ich Problem ist, wenn man das halt so macht,
kann man sagen auch die Schutzwirkung der FFP zwei Maske beeinträchtigen, weil eventuell die nicht mehr so dicht,
ist, weil die nicht dann natürlich nicht dafür gedacht ist, dass man eine OP-Maske da drunter backt, aber äh bei meiner Kombination schien das keinen Unterschied zu machen.
Aber was äh äh bemerkenswert war ist äh ich hatte das Gefühl, dass dass der Trage und Atemkomfort in dieser Kombination,
deutlich angenehmer ist. Also es es wurde nicht so feucht dadrunter und.
Ich hab's jetzt nicht lange ausprobiert, ich hab's jetzt aber nicht draußen äh Praxis länger getragen, sondern um mal so fünf Minuten und habe dabei festgestellt, dass dabei die FFB zwei Maske fast trocken.
Das heißt, da kam dann die Idee, ähm je nachdem, wenn's dicht ist äh und so, ähm dass man halt die billigeren OP-Masken äh quasi häufiger wechselt und seine,
besseren oder teuren FFP zwei oder drei Jahren schont halt,
So, also äh wie gesagt, ist jetzt mit Vorsicht zu genießen das Ganze, aber es war so ein bisschen ein überraschendes Experiment, einfach mal,
Basishalber ausprobieren, äh gucken auch was mit dem Atemwiderstand ist. Ah ja und in dem Zusammenhang weiß ich nicht,
wie das bei dir ist, aber ich habe halt das Problem.
Sagen den Nasenbügel also rechts und links von der Nase des wirklich dicht zu,
kriegen, äh, beim Ausatmen, vor allem strömt da halt Luft in die Augen, was sich ein bisschen unangenehm finde und es reduziert dann natürlich auch die Rückhaltewirkung, wenn das da vorbei geht,
Also man muss sich halt schon Mengen also Mühe geben mit dem Nasenbügel und habe dann gesehen, dass halt Profis, also medizinisches Personal,
teilweise, wenn die wirklich sicher sein wollen, die kleben das zu, die rechts und links über die Nase halt nochmal mit Klebeband den Bereich, damit das halt auch wirklich dicht ist.
Aber ja es gibt aber wohl auch Masken so teure aus Deutschland. Ähm die.
Problem wohl von Hause aus nicht haben, aber ähm an solche luxuriösen Masken äh bin ich jetzt noch nicht rangekommen.
Ja, ich habe äh äh verschiedene Videos gesehen, ähm die auch so mit schon ein bisschen älter sogar.
Es war auch irgend so ein Krankenhaus, Personal sind Krankenschwester, die glaube ich, müssen wir nochmal rausgraben.
Generell die die OP Masken zu diesem Gummidinger quasi über Kreuz genommen hat.
Also dass man nicht einfach nur die Gummiringe so direkt nach hinten zieht, sondern eben nochmal explizit so ein X äh da reinmacht.
Wodurch man nach oben bessere Passform hat. Vielleicht ist das auch etwas, was man nochmal mit dieser FFP zwei Maske kombinieren kann.
Äh ja.
Güter, worüber wir uns hier unterhalten. Unfassbar. Okay, wenn ich mal, wenn ich mal ausprobieren, mal schauen, ich gehe zwar fast gar nicht mehr raus.
Ja, also vor allen Dingen.
Aber so einmal die Woche Supermarkt ist dann doch noch irgendwie angesagt.
Ja, also mein Ding äh ist halt auch, dass ich natürlich auch den äh Situationen grundsätzlich meide, in denen ich äh eine Maske äh auf ähziehen
muss und deswegen ja komme ich vielleicht pro Woche auch vielleicht auf ein, zwei Stunden Maskentragezeit oder so. Ja.
Und ja wie gesagt diese diese Schutzfaktorgeschichte kann man sagen ich hab ich hab da auch ein Shred äh zugetwittert, da stehen dann halt noch ein paar mehr Dinge drin so auch
also ich hab jetzt ein ganz gutes Gefühl eben auch für,
ja Infektionswahrscheinlichkeiten in verschiedenen Situationen äh und ähm.
Ja ähm aber vielleicht nächste Woche mal beleuchten, weil wir haben noch so viele andere äh Themen.
Absolut.
Heute hier und das habe ich jetzt äh ja für die Sendung auch nicht vorbereitet.
Genau, dann gehen wir nochmal auf die aktuellen Zahlen und da hat sich ja einiges getan und ja, das äh schauen wir uns jetzt mal an, wie wir das immer machen.
Wo fangen wir an? Pavel, mach doch mal ein Overview bitte.
Genau, also wie.
Üblich äh so jetzt in Deutschland, ja sind die Neuinfektionen in den letzten sieben Tagen.
Ähm.
Weiter gesunken, äh so auf fünfundfünfzigtausend so mit einem Schnitt von siebentausendneunhundert pro Tag, wobei man dazu sagen muss,
gemeldeten Neuinfektionen ähm so,
und sie gehen weiter zurück, was halt alles ja sehr erfreulich ist so. Äh wir haben im Moment einen,
rechnerischen RW auf Bundesebene von null Komma acht sechs.
Nach Rechtenverfahren, aber äh wir nehmen immer irgendwie meins, was darauf beruht, halt einfach die Fälle von äh,
den letzten sieben Tagen und den sieben Tagen davor ins Verhältnis zu setzen äh und äh dann ja,
daraus den R Wert zu berechnen. Ich glaube hoch vier siebte.
Ähm ja ähm,
und wie gesagt, rechnerisch äh ist ja sogar unter null Komma neun, aber und sage immer, dann hinterher nochmal,
bisschen genauer ein, äh da die Tests auch abgenommen haben ist, was die Infektion angeht, der reale RWT eher.
Etwas über null Komma neun, weil im Moment die Zahlen, die wir sehen, äh.
Unterschätzen, äh die Infektion beziehungsweise überschätzen den Rückgang, also die äh die Dunkelziffer hat halt weiter zugenommen, weil eben weniger Tests äh gemacht wurden.
Ja, äh glücklicherweise geht auch die Zahl der Toten äh jetzt.
Deutlich nach unten oder sogar etwas stärker äh nach unten als sie es davor,
getan hat, die gut es läuft ja immer ein bisschen zeitlich versetzt und wir kommen halt,
jetzt in den Bereich, wo dann endlich auch die Zahl,
der Toten deutlich fällt sind, aber äh immer noch äh über fünfhundert pro Tag im Schnitt.
Und ähm ja.
Das ist natürlich immer noch viel zu viel zu viel, aber zumindest äh der Trend stimmt grade,
aber das sind immer noch ja doppelt so viele oder fast doppelt so viele wie auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle muss man sich auch.
Mal vergegenwärtigen, so wobei bei der ersten Welle der Höhepunkt der Toten ungefähr äh ja zweieinhalb Wochen äh nach dem Höhepunkt.
Bei den Neuinfektionen erreicht war ähm jetzt hier in der zweiten Welle,
sind es ja auch ungefähr zwei bis drei Wochen, kann man sagen, sieht man ganz ganz gut.
Dass vielleicht äh zu den er Entwicklung der Zahlen, ansonsten ähm wenn man jetzt ein bisschen in die Bundesländer noch.
Äh kurz an der Stelle du hast ja jetzt auch schon die äh die Tests erwähnt, vielleicht sollten wir die Zahl nochmal kurz mit reinnehmen, weil ich finde, finde jetzt gerade diese ganze Korrelation,
ganz interessant. Wir hatten das ja letztes Mal auch schon ein bisschen angesprochen,
Also du hast ja gesagt, die Tests sind ein bisschen zurückgegangen, ne? Also wir haben Rückgänge von den Tests, was war das? Zehn Prozent weniger.
Neun Komma sieben fünf Prozent weniger Tests auf Bundesebene.
Genau, es ist aber auch die positiven Quote ist auch zurückgegangen.
Um sieben Komma eins fünf Prozent ist die positiven Rate zurückgegangen.
Und die Zahl der positiven Tests ist um sechzehn Komma zwei Prozent zurückgegangen hier.
Was halt ja sozusagen in den Betrachtungszeitraum dann, dass es jetzt nicht genau,
sagen die letzten sieben Tage, sondern es ist halt ähm immer RKI Woche so, also von ist halt drei Tage zurück und da äh,
waren zu sagen sechzehn Komma zwei Prozent weniger positive Tests, das heißt sechzehn Komma zwei Prozent,
weniger neu infiziert, könnte man jetzt einfach annehmen oder so geht es halt bei uns in die Statistik,
rein, so aber ähm wenn,
jetzt sagen die Infektionsaktivität gar nicht zurückgegangen wäre.
Einfach nur zehn Prozent weniger Tests gemacht würden würde die Zahl der positiven Tests auch um vielleicht nicht ganz zehn Prozent, aber fast zehn Prozent äh zurück.
Und es heißt statt unseren sechzehn Komma zwei Prozent.
Was uns die Zahlen jetzt sagen, haben wir in Wahrheit, was jetzt reale Infektionen angeht, wahrscheinlich eher so.
Ja acht bis zwölf Prozent realen Rückgang, das heißt im Moment muss man halt deswegen äh die Zahlen äh ja.
Ein bisschen erhöhen eigentlich, weil wir systematische Unterschätzung haben.
Trotzdem ist natürlich, dass äh der Fall die fallende Zahl bei den Positivraten ist, die eigentlich gute Nachricht.
Ich glaube, ich hatte das letzte Mal schon mal erwähnt, aber ich find's nochmal wertvoll, das zu wiederholen. Wenn man sich jetzt mal nur den Verlauf der Positivrate anschaut, also nicht immer nur guckt
so und so viele Leute sind getestet worden, wie viele von davon waren positiv. Wir haben immer gesehen, immer in dem Moment, wo es loskrieselte und wo die Welle kam.
Geht diese positiv Rate hinterher, was also im Prinzip bedeutet, das sind eigentlich auch sehr viel mehr Leute positiv, als man eigentlich ähm wirklich real,
testet. Und erst wenn diese Zahl wieder runter geht, kommt man quasi mit der Testerei, dem eigentlichen Infektionsgeschehen so ein bisschen auf eine Spur,
und einen Fall eine positive Rate, ist ein guter Indikator. Und ich habe das lange Zeit so als so ein
Na ja, so ein so ein so ein, so ein Nebenabattribut angesehen, aber wenn man sich eben jetzt den Verlauf der Positivrate, über die komplette, über das komplette letzte Jahr anschaut,
dann sieht man.
Dass die relativ gut die äh den Gesamtverlauf der Panemie nachzeichnet, sehr grob, also dadurch aber auch sehr gut geglättet in gewisser Hinsicht. Ist jetzt nichts, was einem,
eine große Auskunft über einen Zeitraum von vier, vier Wochen oder so sagt, aber ist äh etwas, was sehr gut widerspiegelt, was so in drei Monaten passiert.
Würde ich mal sagen und nach wie vor, also jetzt auch mit dieser ähm niedrigen Positivrad, also noch nicht niedrig genug,
immerhin niedriger mit dieser niedrigeren Positivrate von sieben Komma was war das jetzt? Sieben Komma acht, sind Komma fünf.
Sieben Komma acht sechs.
Sieben Komma acht sechs äh Prozent sind wir halt.
In etwa da, wo die erste Welle in Deutschland anfing, wieder zurückzugehen. Also, wir sind sozusagen beim Höhepunkt der ersten Welle. Da waren wir letzte Woche im Prinzip auch schon mal so.
Ja, ein bis zwei, wir sind so ein bis zwei Wochen nach dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle. Jetzt mit der positiven Rate.
Ein bis zwei Wochen danach, okay?
Liegt genau zwischen äh also wenn man jetzt in die in die Tabelle äh reinguckt,
Dann hatten wir von KW vierzehn auf KW fünfzehn hier von,
auf sechzehn sind wir von sechs sieben Komma neun acht auf sechs Komma sechs acht runtergegangen und
während der ersten Welle und wir liegen jetzt irgendwo mitten dazwischen, deswegen sozusagen. Und der Höhepunkt war neun Komma null drei in KW vierzehn, also sind,
ein bis zwei Wochen jetzt nach dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle mit der positiven Rate, wenn man das jetzt vergleichen will.
OK und meiner Meinung nach kann man da zwei Sachen draus lesen. Also erstens ist jetzt in dem Sinne keine Neuigkeit mehr, aber man kann im Prinzip die erste Welle jetzt nochmal so neu kalibrieren, ne? Und man sieht einfach, dass dass das Infektionsgeschehen, was wir beobachtet haben.
Vermutlich mal locker um Faktor zwei höher war, wenn nicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr. Ich hab's jetzt nicht wirklich nachgerechnet. Ähm als wir es wahrgenommen haben. Und dass wir jetzt und vielleicht war es nicht ganz so.
Es wird aber nicht ganz so hoch gewesen sein, wie jetzt diese zweite Welle, weil das können wir dann wiederum an den Toten zahlen, ganz gut ablesen.
Dass dass wir da nun wirklich ja um Faktor äh was ist das? Ordnung mal Faktor vier drüber liegen, ne?
Ja gut, wir lagen aber auch bei den sagen wir die Infektion. Also wenn man das alles so zusammennimmt, äh äh so kommt man irgendwo,
auf, dass während der ersten Welle ähm irgendwo zwischen fünfzig und hundert Prozent.
Die Dunkelziffer höher war während der ersten Welle, als sie jetzt ist, weil natürlich auch,
jetzt schon trotz des Rückgangs, wir haben jetzt ungefähr rund eine Million Tests pro Woche und in dem Zeitraum.
Wir ja vierhundertsechzehntausend Tests und das heißt wir testen jetzt doppelt so viel und dementsprechend,
kann man dann auch erwarten bei gleicher.
Positiven Quote, doppelt so viele Tests, dass die Dunkelziffer jetzt niedriger ist als die Uhr in der ersten Welle.
Genau, warum erwill ich das jetzt nochmal? Einfach unter um nochmal klarzumachen, ähm diese zweite Welle ist jetzt noch mit noch lange nicht vorbei,
und es gibt halt eigentlich relativ wenig Anlass jetzt nachzulassen. Wir haben das ja auch mehrfach betont. Der Ehrwert ist einfach zu hoch dafür. Ist schön, dass er unter eins ist. Schön, dass er unter eins bleibt und jetzt seit zwei, drei Wochen unter eins ist. Aber wir würden halt,
sehr viel mehr vom Leben haben in diesem Jahr, wenn wir es halt irgendwie schaffen würden, den noch noch viel, viel, viel niedriger zu bekommen. Also irgendwie ähm eine Woche oder zwei Wochen mal so auf null Komma sieben zu kommen. Das das wäre würde so viel bringen
nur na ja das sehen wir ja dann auch gleich nochmal. Natürlich geht jetzt schon wieder diese Lockerungsdebatte los und allein, dass die Debatte jetzt angefangen hat.
Wird uns wahrscheinlich die nächsten Ergebnisse auch wieder verhageln. Also ich,
bin jetzt nicht mehr sehr optimistisch, was äh das Einfangen dieser Welle betrifft, sondern ich,
wenn ich pessimistisch draufblicke, ist das jetzt sozusagen der der Anfang vom vom vom Ende der Erholung.
Ja, es wird interessant, so in zwei, drei Wochen zu sehen, meine These ist, dass diese Debatte jetzt, diese Öffnungsdebatte, die jetzt geführt wurde, wahrscheinlich unmittelbar,
zu 'nem Ansteigen des geführt hat,
Aber das werden wir halt frühestens in zwei oder drei Wochen äh wissen und dann nachvollziehen können.
So ob dem tatsächlich so ist, ob das jetzt einen Einfluss hatte und.
Ja am Ende des Tages so, also bei mir verfestigt sich das Gefühl, dass ungefähr zwei Drittel vom RWT äh.
Auf das individuelle Verhalten der Leute äh zurückzuführen ist und ungefähr ein Drittel vom RW auf staatliche Maßnahmen.
Zu ähm das ist jetzt sehr sehr grob.
Aber ähm ja, der RWT sinkt und steigt auch ohne Loktown, weil die Leute halt vorsichtiger werden, wenn Hiobsbotschaften kommen, wenn sie.
In den Medien halt dramatische Bilder sehen und ähm dann passten die Leute von alleine mehr auf.
Ja und auch nochmal an den Dingen äh Kids mehrfach nachvoll. Also die Politik oder der Logdown äh.
Ist immer etwas, das kommt halt, nachdem die Leute schon begonnen haben, zu reagieren. Also die sagen, die Politik vollzieht nach. Ähm was so die Stimmung äh in der Bevölkerung ist.
Meistens leider zu spät und äh ja die Bevölkerung nimmt auch die Lockerung vorweg, also sobald über Lockerungen geredet wird, äh verstehen das eine Reihe von Leuten als Entwarnung.
Ist jetzt nicht mehr so schlimm, weil wird ja demnächst gelockert, dann äh.
Genau. Ist es ja schon locker. Genau, obwohl jetzt offiziell natürlich die Maßnahmen heißen der Loktan äh soll noch bis was war das jetzt bis siebten März laufen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite öffnen halt jetzt ab dem zweiundzwanzigsten Februar teilweise eben schon wieder die Grundschulen und die Kitas und das ist halt,
Na ja, so sehr ich das verstehen kann, dass Leute sich da Entlastungen wünschen, dass es halt, ja, immer wieder dasselbe Spiel.
Ja, wie schneidet man sich eigentlich ins eigene Fleisch, weil.
Auch der jetzige Lokdown, ich meine, wenn man die Zahlen, wenn man die Bilder so nebeneinander sieht, die zweite.
Welle hätte nicht größer ausfallen müssen als die Erste.
Sie ist aber von der Höhe her ja, es ist drei bis vier Mal so hoch äh geschwappt, ja.
Nachdem und äh wenn man sich dann die Fläche unter der Kurve äh anguckt, das ist dann nämlich repräsentiert äh die Zahl der infizierten äh.
Dann würde ich sagen ist das irgendwo zwischen zehn und zwanzig so leicht visuell kann man wahrscheinlich dann auch sich mal nachrechnen, ja? Aber wir haben ja die zweite Welle zehn bis zwanzig Mal so schlimm gemacht.
Wie sie hätte sein müssen und vier bis fünf Mal so lang wie sie hätte sein müssen.
Eigentlich werden wir mit vier bis sechs Wochen ja wenn wir locker hingekommen, wenn wir das wie in der ersten Welle gemacht hätten.
Und jetzt sind wir seit was eins, zwei, drei, vier, ja, über vier Monate sind wir jetzt dabei.
Ja und haben sechs Mal so viele Tote wie wir vorher hatten.
Pro Tag nicht über den Gesamt, hm.
Insgesamt. Also wir haben jetzt insgesamt so fünfundsechzigtausend äh Trutte zu beklagen insgesamt in Deutschland und wir waren halt im Sommer so bei zwischen neun und zehntausend.
Ich sagte, dass die Gesamtzahl der der Toten in Deutschland halt durch die zweite Welle sich eben dann nochmal versechsfacht hat.
Okay, ja, ja. Faktor sechs, ja. Also sagen ja, die zweite Welle war in dem Sinne jetzt äh und wir sind ja noch nicht zu Ende. Wir sind ja noch nicht du.
Nee, wir sind nicht nicht nicht durch und das äh kann sich dann locker auch noch verzehnfachen und äh wird es wahrscheinlich auch.
Also Faktor, also wir haben zehn bis zwanzig Mal es schlimmer gemacht in der zweiten Welle äh als äh in der ersten und das hätte nicht sein müssen.
Nee, absolut nicht.
Kann man auch an anderen Ländern sehen, äh die das genauso hingekriegt haben. Die haben halt äh in der zweiten Welle äh äh hat die nicht schlimmer getroffen als die Erste.
Und auch nicht schlimmer als als Deutschland. Ja.
Finnland zum Beispiel.
Norwegen.
Norwegen. Gibt viele.
Auch ganz gut unter Kontrolle gekriegt und Dänemark ist auch nicht schlecht so. Ja und wir haben jetzt natürlich äh unser gesamtes,
Inhaltsverzeichnis unsere gesamte Vorbereitung.
War nicht über den Haufen geworfen, aber jetzt schon mal wild durch alle Themen durch Macht, aber glaube ich nichts, oder?
Nee, ganz so wild ist es auch nicht. Wir können ja mal ein bisschen auf die Bundesländer schauen, wie sich das da auf äh fächert.
Mhm. Da ist vielleicht,
wichtig zu erwähnen bei den Bundesländern nicht in allen Bundesländern gehen die Zahlen derzeit zurück, also in Hamburg und Niedersachsen haben wir ganz,
leichte Anstiege, minimal ein Prozent in Hamburg und Niedersachsen null Komma drei ist, also
praktisch nichts, aber die Zahlen gehen dort nicht runter und auch in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben wir nur minus zwei Prozent, das heißt, wenn wir auf jeden Fall aktuell gerade drei Bundesländer, wo
schon mal der Rückgang gerade zum Stillstand gekommen ist, ja. Und in gut in allen anderen Ländern, also,
sind so zwischen minus acht Prozent und minus dreiunddreißig Prozent
also minus dreiunddreißig ist Brandenburg äh gerade und äh ja die Wenigsten aber doch noch signifikanten Rückgänge sind so Saarland und Schleswig-Holstein.
Und ja ansonsten haben wir halt auch noch die Verteilung.
Dass eben weiterhin die Ostländer mit Ausnahme von Berlin.
Und dann Bayern, Niedersachsen, Hamburg und Saarland gerade schlechter sind als der Bundesschnitt.
Jetzt nicht mehr nur noch Ostländer äh.
Schwabb doch wieder in den Westen rüber.
Ja und höre dann nochmal auf die Top dreißig Landkreise auf äh Pavel Maier DE, Corona Risks.
Guckt ähm,
dann ist aber dort hauptsächlich gerade Bayern und Thüringen vertreten, die machen so die halben,
Top dreißig voll mit acht Mal Bayern und acht Mal Thüringen. So, dann haben wir noch viermal Niedersachsen.
Zweimal Brandenburg, zweimal Schleswig-Holstein und dann sind aber auch noch Nordrhein-Westfalen, Baden-Württemberg, Sachsen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Rheinland-Pfalz vertreten. Also man sieht schon, äh wir haben halt schon ganz viele Hotspots,
verteilt über fast alle Länder, ja? Also.
Kann jetzt nicht sagen, ja, dass es jetzt gut, ja, Bayern und Thüringen, wie gesagt, aber äh wenn man sie auf die Landkreise guckt, so, dann,
ähm brennt das äh an verschiedenen Stellen immer noch, also in ein,
zu einem Landkreisen, Lichterloh. Was natürlich auch nicht gut ist für irgendwelche Lockerungen, weil das sind dann natürlich alles dann die Punkte oder die Gegenden, wo es dann sofort äh wieder explodiert, wenn man anfängt.
Wobei die meisten Landkreise davon, die waren jetzt nicht unbedingt Dauergast, also so teilweise
die vielleicht auch erstmalig richtig Feuer bekommen haben. Das einzige was ich hier auf den ersten Blick sehe, was so ein totaler Dauerbrenner ist, dass es hier so Tirschenreuth in Bayern,
keine Ahnung was was bei denen so äh läuft, aber die scheinen einfach nichts gelernt zu haben in dieser ganzen Zeit, das ist
bisschen erschreckend finde ich, dass dass ein Landkreis sich wirklich so dauerhaft unter den den Kernproblembereichen, ähm, des Landes bewegen kann und dann auch um die Ecke Hof ist auch äh regelmäßig vertreten.
Habe ich jetzt nicht so in Erinnerung, dass da so viel passiert ist. Das kann man dann auch immer ganz, ganz gut äh daran festmachen, wie viel ähm Fälle es insgesamt bisher äh schon gegeben hat,
Also relativ zur Bevölkerungszahl und da sind die dann halt auch irgendwie alle nicht so schlecht vertreten.
Und in Vechta ist irgendwas los gerade, da hat sich da haben sich die Zahlen irgendwie verdoppelt gerade.
Irgend so ein super Sprenner-Event wahrscheinlich wieder, ne? Ja, aber hier so Hildburghausen, in in Thüringen, Tirschenreuth.
Bayern, wenn man also da mal auf die Gesamtzahl der Fälle schaut, das ist halt äh,
alles so im also Fälle je hunderttausend sind die halt so im fünftausend Plus Bereich angesiedelt. Ähm, das bedeutet das also schon über.
Fünf Prozent aller Leute, die dort in diesem Landkreis gemeldet sind, äh,
positiv getestet wurden, ne? Da noch Dunkelziffer obendrauf kann man sich äh vorstellen, was äh abgeht, ne, wenn man mal so die aktuellen Rekordhalter anschaut, also was ist sozusagen der
bisher insgesamt am stärksten betroffenen Landkreis. Da hat Sachsen ja komplett das äh Regime übernommen.
In den letzten Wochen und Monaten, also Bautzen, geht da mit sechs Komma drei Prozent voran.
Gefolgt vom sächsische Schweiz, Osterzgebirge, Erzgebirgskreis.
Also jeweils mit sechs Prozent knapp Görlitz, fünf Komma acht Prozent dann eben wie schon erwähnt, Thüringen, Hildburghausen, Zwickau.
Fünf Komma fünf Prozent. Also es ist wirklich Sachsen, Sachsen, Sachsen, Thüringen, Sachsen, Sachsen und dann geht's Bayern und Thüringen und so weiter und das ist irgendwie so, das sind so die Problembereiche, das sind einfach so diese ganzen Landkreise, in denen einfach.
Ordentlich gearbeitet wird. Das kann man aber glaube ich immer so festhalten.
Mhm. Ja.
Also selbst das schlimme Berliner Neukölln ähm ja arrangiert da zwar auch noch relativ weit oben aber äh davor kommen interessanterweise lauter Landkreise.
Wobei interessanterweise auch noch der der Sachsen-Durchschnitt ist schlimmer als Neukölln äh oder die ja die.
Stimmt.
Ja, okay.
Kleine Korrektur noch, du hast deine eigene URL falsch erinnert, das ist natürlich Pavel Meier DE Slash Kowitz Slash Risk und nicht Slash Corona Slash Risks, ne? Also ihr findet die URL aber auch immer in unseren Shownotes, wenn ihr auf Pavels Tabelle kommen wollt.
Ja und da könnt ihr dann genauso in den Zahlen rumfachsimpeln, wie wir das jetzt hier tun. Ich glaube, mehr müssen wir jetzt hier aus dieser Liste auch nicht unbedingt zitieren.
Es lässt sich zusammenfassen, die Probleme sind äh stark lokaler Natur. Es gibt einfach eine Menge Bereiche, die es ganz gut in Griff kriegen,
Aber es wird dann halt einfach durch äh ja besonders stark wütende Landkreise alles immer schnell wieder aus der Spur gebracht.
Ja. Willst du dann noch zu Berlin erstmal was sagen, bevor wir auf die Impfstatistiken kommen.
Ja, Berlin können wir dann auch nochmal nochmal kurz machen eigentlich, weil Berlin ist,
Prinzip fast wie bunt die Situation, also etwas niedrigere Institenz mit siebzig in Berlin versus neunundsiebzig.
Im Bund. Ähm ja.
Ehrwert ist praktisch gleich äh gerade, also da nimmt sich,
Berlin und der Bund nicht viel. Ich nehme halt auch immer deswegen Berlin ganz gerne äh dazu, weil hm.
Ja wenn man halt ganz Deutschland sieht ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich.
Aufwärtstrends mit Abwärtstrends woanders
irgendwo ausgleichen und dass man da an einem eventuell nicht so ein gutes Bild hat. Außerdem habe ich halt für Berlin immer ganz gute Zahlen für,
die Verteilung in den Altersgruppen und für die Auslastung der Krankenhäuser und so ähm deswegen ja also ganz ganz kurz.
Verlauf, ähnlich äh wie im Bund positiven Rate auch, ist sogar jetzt äh auf sieben Komma fünf Prozent gesunken. Also jetzt niedriger als im Bund,
jetzt ja wie auf dem Höhepunkt,
der ersten Welle, die Zahl der Tests in Berlin ist sogar noch stärker gesunken, etwas um zehn Komma acht Prozent, das heißt,
Wir haben auch dort die Situation, dass äh sagen,
der zwar dreiundzwanzig Prozent weniger gezählte Fälle haben aber tatsächlich ist der Rückgang bisschen geringer, wahrscheinlich eher so, weiß ich nicht, fünfzehn Prozent oder so, was die Infektionstätigkeit angeht,
und dankenswerterweise.
Geht auch die Institanz in allen Altersgruppen weiter nach un.
So. Ähm ja, liegen zwar immer noch ein bisschen auseinander, aber.
Ja es es bewegt sich alles in die richtige Richtung gerade.
Also ich sehe gerade hier achtzig Plus geht auch extrem stark zurück, aber ist halt nach wie vor die am stärksten betroffene Gruppe.
Es sind jetzt glaube ich in Berlin. Gott, jetzt habe ich die Zahlen nicht, wir kommen gleich nochmal zu den Impfstatistiken, aber auch hier müsste sich dann in den nächsten paar Wochen langsam mal die Impferei,
zeigen, also zumindest in dieser einen Altersgruppe, weil die natürlich jetzt bevorzugt geimpft wurden.
Ich glaube, dass so eine Weile, aber.
Kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Mach erstmal fertig. Mhm.
Ja, aber wo es sich auf jeden Fall bemerkbar macht äh ist äh so bei der Auslastung der Krankenhäuser und Intensivstationen. So ähm.
Da haben wir ja einen einen deutlichen Rückgang, also vom vom Höhepunkt.
Sind wir jetzt.
Haben wir ein Drittel äh weniger als äh Patienten im Krankenhaus, als auf dem Höhepunkt. Also sind im Moment noch so in Berlin liegen etwa tausend Menschen in Krankenhäusern und,
ein Drittel davon ungefähr auf Intensivstationen und äh auch noch ein interessanter Wert äh.
So bisher ist so in etwa jeder fünfte Patient verstorben.
Also bezogen auf die kompletten tausend, nicht auf die Intensiv nur alleine und ähm ja.
Dass.
Ist natürlich alles nicht so schön, also in Berlin sind halt sagen jetzt dort dreitausenddreiundsechzig Personen klinisch verstorben. Ähm also in Krankenhäusern und ungefähr zwölfeinhalbtausend.
Wurden entlassen. Hoffentlich möglichst.
Gesund äh und möglichst ohne allzu viele Langzeitschäden, aber ja und irgendwie zweihundertfünfzig Leute werden beatmet im Moment in Berlin gerade. Also ich finde.
Das schon ganz schön.
Bitter, immer noch. Das ist ganz schön bitter, wenn ich mir so vorstelle irgendwie dreihundert Beatmungen, so.
Das ist ja ein riesen Ding.
Und ja das wär's vielleicht jetzt zu den Zahlen soweit zu den, also zu den Infektionen.
Genau. Zahlen haben wir auch noch andere, nämlich äh schauen jetzt mal auf den Fortschritt bei der Impfkampagne in Deutschland,
da geht's natürlich nicht besonders schnell voran, aber es geht,
voran. Es gibt ja, haben wir auch glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, kann man aber jetzt glaube ich äh nochmal erwähnen. Diese Webseite impft-Dashboard Punkt DE.
Wo mittlerweile sogar ganz brauchbar die Fortschritte zusammengefasst werden. Am Anfang war das so ein bisschen na ja, ich fand es ein bisschen oberflächlich, aber mittlerweile gibt's da ein paar,
detaillierte Grafiken, die das dann mal sehr gut anzeigen, also sowohl wie viele Leute sind geimpft, wie es wird auch unterschieden zwischen Erstimpfung und Zweitimpfung, es wird aufgebrochen nach täglich verabreichten
Impfdosen auch nochmal unterschieden nach Erstimpfung und Zweitimpfung und was ich auch sehr schön finde,
dass sie eben auch die Impfstofflieferungen abbilden und äh das nicht nur insgesamt, sondern tatsächlich auch aufgesplittet nach den einzelnen,
Lieferanten, also man sieht was, wie viel ist von
Bei uns Pfeifer gekommen, wie viel ist von Astra Senika gekommen, wie viel ist von moderner gekommen. Das sind jetzt sozusagen alle drei, also jetzt sozusagen seit der letzten Woche, seit dem sechsten zweiten, ist halt jetzt Astra Sinneka noch mit dazu gekommen
schon jetzt äh sind mehr Impfstoffe von Astra Sinika geliefert worden, als zum Beispiel von moderner.
Ja, ja, da können wir mal konkret drauf eingehen. Das Ganze ist halt auch also eigentlich ganz, ganz schön gestaltet, weil du hast sozusagen Impfstoffherkunft und Impfstoffverwendung so ein bisschen wie so eine Bilanz.
Wo du auch Mittelherkunft und Mittelverwendung hast oder auch so ein bisschen wie ähm.
Wo man auch sehen kann, dass es zum Beispiel nicht ein Problem der Termine ist oder es ist kein Problem der Effizienz der der Impfzentren,
es ist einfach ein Versorgungsproblem. Wir wir verimpfen das was kommt. Es kommt aber nicht genug.
Also konkret äh haben wir jetzt wurden jetzt,
lassen Sie mal eben schnell einmal runter brechen. So vier Komma sechs Millionen Dosenimpfstoff wurden geliefert,
so äh davon war,
waren fast neunzig Prozent äh Bayerntech Pfeiser, also über vier Millionen Dosen, das heißt, das ist sagen der Hauptstoff,
und ja an zweiter Stelle du schon gesagt hast, mit dann sieben Komma vier Prozent äh ist jetzt schon Astra Sinnika dabei während,
moderner bisher nur mit hundertfünfzigtausend Dosen gerade mal auf drei Komma drei Prozent äh der
Impfstoff äh Lieferungen äh ausmacht. Was mich dann auch immer interessiert hat, wie wie groß sind denn die Reserven äh eigentlich? Wie viel wird denn jetzt zurückgelegt,
Und da hat man im Gegensatz zu hm ja als ich das letzte Mal vor zwei Wochen oder so geguckt,
habe.
War noch deutlich mehr auf Lager. Jetzt sieht so aus, dass achtzig Prozent von dem, was geliefert wurde.
Schon verimpft wurde und wir haben im Moment nach den Zahlen so neunhundertzwanzigtausend Dosen auf Lager und,
reicht so für acht bis neun Tage bei dem gegenwärtigen Impftempo, also so bestückt, das heißt,
Man könnte so eine Woche ungefähr äh Lieferausfall überbrücken äh äh damit im Moment aber nicht mehr ähm.
Da segelt man schon hart am Wind.
Auf jeden Fall so und dann äh.
Sagen, wer hat's jetzt gekriegt? Das fand ich auch überraschend, weil siebenundvierzig Prozent sind an Gesundheits und
Pflegeberufe gegangen. Ich hätte ja eher gedacht, dass das meiste an ältere Menschen gegangen sind, aber die kommen nur
auf Platz zwei mit rund sechsunddreißig Prozent, somit.
Achtundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent sind Pflegeheimbewohner ähm.
Das sind sicherlich auch ältere Menschen und das ist aber dann nochmal zusätzlich, ne.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind halt äh sagen die, die jetzt nicht in äh sagen, das sind zwei verschiedene Gruppen. Äh äh äh,
schon und das sind dann also dementsprechend jüngere Pflegeheimbewohner wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin.
Nein, ich denke, dass es das ist so gemeint, achtundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent der verimpften Dosen sind an Pflegeheimbewohner gegangen. Fünfunddreißig Komma sieben Prozent sind andere ältere Menschen gegangen, die nicht in einem Pflegeheim leben,
knapp siebenundvierzig Prozent der Dosen sind einem an Gesundheits- und Pflegeberufe gegangen. So ist es gemeint,
dann nochmal drei Komma sieben Prozent an Menschen mit Vorerkrankung.
Womit wir aber über hundert Prozent wären.
Ist es so ähm das.
Sieben, acht, neun, ja. Das ist eine interessante Feststellung. Dann äh kann ich daraus nur schließendes mehr als hundert Prozent äh Impfstoffe geliefert wurden.
Ja. Oder es gibt doch Überschneidungen zwischen den Personengruppen oder äh ohne die Bundesregierung kann nicht rechnen.
Oder das Impf der Sport könnte ich rechnen. Das liebe ich immer so
das ist das ist gut. Ich glaube, ich ähm weiß, wer hinter diesem Dashboard äh steckt, äh werde ich die Person mal drauf hinweisen. Das geht ja so nicht. Ähm okay,
Sagen wir mal ganz gnädig und sagen wir mal grob ein Großteil knapp die Hälfte geht sozusagen
an Leute, die im Gesundheitswesen arbeiten, also Mitarbeiter von Pflege,
rufen und Krankenhäusern und so weiter, Ärzte, was weiß ich und der Rest äh kümmert sich eigentlich um Leute
Betreuung und Leute die besonders gefährdet sind eben ältere und Leute mit Vorerkrankung und das ist sozusagen das was derzeit verimpft wird, also hier sind keine Impfdosen an jüngere Menschen gegangen zum Beispiel,
oder die keine,
Krankung haben. Mit Ausnahmen hier und da immer mal wieder also so wie ich das gehört habe. Man hat ja immer wieder diese Situation, dass am Ende des Tages Impfdosen übrig bleiben.
Aus bekannten Gründen, da geht's dann halt nicht auf, dann äh hat man halt so sechs Dosierungen in so einem Fläschchen, das Fläschchen ist offen. Es ist kein Termin mehr da. Äh,
Hast du nur die Wahl zwischen irgendjemand impfen, der gerade rumsteht? Und ähm wegschmeißen und dann geht's halt dann äh doch auch zum Beispiel auf die Leute, die in Impfzentren arbeiten und häufig wird dann auch mal so die Feuerwehr gerufen und.
Einfach auch nochmal mitgeimpft, was ich völlig in Ordnung finde.
Mühlen, das ist schon okay, interessant, finde ich noch, weil sie auch überraschend fand oder nicht so überraschend, aber bemerkenswert. Ähm dass,
Personen mit Vorerkrankung des doch recht schwierig äh haben. Also entweder gibt's nicht so viele davon, aber ich habe eben auch gehört,
sagen medizinische Indikation ist halt schwierig. So im Moment,
Bei Alter ist halt alles klar und Pflegeheim auch, aber bei äh offensichtlich machen sie es Personen mit Vorerkrankungen gerade doch nicht leicht. Äh so da gab's ja auch schon Leute, die das dann eingeklagt,
haben erfolgreich, andere, die es nicht hatten, keinen Erfolg vor Gericht äh.
Also das ist so ein Thema. Medizinische Indikation.
Also insgesamt sind drei Komma sieben Millionen Dosierungen verabreicht worden. Das betrifft.
Ja also vier Komma vier Prozent, also das bezieht sich ja auf erste und zweite, ne? Also drei drei Prozent der Einwohner haben die erste Dosis erhalten,
eins Komma vier Prozent haben die Zweitdosis erhalten oder man könnte halt aber auch anders sagen, also eins Komma vier Prozent der Bevölkerung sind jetzt so richtig durchgeimpft,
ne? Und in spätestens zwei Wochen sind diese eins Komma vier Prozent eben theoretisch auch auf dem Maximum ihrer Resistenz, die sie sich von diesem,
Impfstoff versprechen können. Aber wie entwickelt sich das jetzt, ne?
Du hast jetzt auch nochmal genauer angeschaut, da auch nochmal eine Grafik gemacht, hier haben wir dann auch einen Blog, die Impfgeschwindigkeit nimmt nicht zu.
Ne. Ähm also äh oder so äh doch äh sie nimmt. Also es wird mehr geimpft äh so,
nach wie vor sie mit mit jeder Woche aber die Zunahme jede Woche wird gerade kleiner, also wir haben sozusagen eher so eine logarithmische, abflachende Kurve, die zwar immer noch nach oben geht, aber eigentlich,
wollen wir auch bei den Impfstoffen äh eher die schöne ähm.
Weil wir einen Röser eins haben.
Gibt noch eine eine exponentielle äh Kurve äh.
Ja 'ne Exponenten über eins, so der halt also wir wollen Beschleunigung und im Moment.
Massiv, aber,
Das hängt halt und das lässt sich ja aus den anderen Zahlen auch herauslesen. Es hängt halt einfach an der Lieferung. Also es ist halt einfach gar nicht mehr da. Man könnte da jetzt so impfen, äh so viel impfen wollen, wie man will, äh ist einfach nicht genug da. Das ist eine Situation.
Die sich bessern wird.
Und äh in diesem Monat geht ja die neue Produktionsstätte auch äh an Start in Marburg von Faiser. Das wird dann interessant werden äh.
Wann man davon eine Auswirkung sehen kann.
Ja? Also ich bin eh mal davon ausgegangen hier auch gesagt, dass ich nicht glaube, dass,
vor April das so richtig losgeht. Also das ist klar, wird mehr werden irgendwie Mitte Ende März soll auch nochmal was kommen und im Februar war ja auch nochmal deutlich,
mehr Dosen äh an äh gesagt, also sind so Zahlen für den Februar,
eigentlich so irgendwas von fünf bis sieben Millionen insgesamt avisiert an.
Dosen und da sind wir aber noch deutlich von entfernt, also bei.
Aktueller Geschwindigkeit ähm würden wir eher so, ja, auf drei bis vier Millionen pro Monat.
Jetzt, also für den Februar, so und nicht auf die sieben oder es waren glaube ich sogar mal zwölf Millionen oder so irgendwie im.
Im Gespräch oder oder ursprünglich, das wurde dann äh ja äh dann dann wieder reduziert, aber.
Also im Moment die realen Zahlen bleiben noch hinter allem zurück, was irgendwo mal angekündigt.
Na gut. Vielleicht an der Stelle äh auch gleich nochmal der Vergleich mit äh Israel,
einfach aus dem Grund, weil Israel ja so ein bisschen der
in der ganzen Impferei ist, das haben wir ja hier auch schon angesprochen und es ist natürlich auch insofern interessant, äh, sich das anzuschauen, als dass wir da ein absehbarer Zeit auch belastbare Zahlen zu der Wirkung der Impfstoffe oder zumindest es dort primär eingesetzten Impfstoffs, nämlich des Pfeiser
Biontisch im Stoffs äh erwarten. Das Data-Dashboard von Israel ist sehr auskunftsfreudig und ähm ja
vielleicht erstmal generell ein äh Vergleich zwischen Israel und Deutschland, wie das eigentlich da so Corona mäßig gerade aussieht, ist auch ganz interessant, weil
Israela, zum Beispiel dieselbe positiven Quote wie Deutschland. Ja, also wir haben ja gerade eben viel über diese positiven Quote gesprochen und.
Die Linien sind dann sozusagen relativ deckungsgleich. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie aber deutlich höhere äh Infektionszahlen.
Und zwar Faktor sieben zu eins. Also es ist einfach das Infektionsgeschehen ist da gerade total rampend. Und.
Die haben halt auch einen extrem hohen Anteil an dieser äh UK Virus Variante.
Andererseits haben sie deutlich niedrige Totenzahlen und ne, also haben auch denselben Trend wie Deutschland, aber äh deutlich niedrigere Sterbezahlen und das war aber auch schon immer so.
So dass man hier mutmaßen kann, dem bin ich aber jetzt nicht weiter nachgegangen, dass ich hier einfach die Altersstrukturen der Bevölkerung an sich widerspiegelt.
Kann natürlich auch bedeuten, dass äh deswegen vielleicht auch.
Dass der alles nicht so ernst genommen wurde et cetera. Nichtsdestotrotz, es wird ordentlich geimpft und es geht weiter weiter äh schnell voran. Hat zwar ein bisschen nachgelassen,
Gibt's auch so erste Berichte, dass jetzt irgendwie durch die ultraorthodoxen und andere Gruppen natürlich man kommt jetzt sozusagen auch in zunehmendem Maße in den Bereich der Skeptiker.
Nichtsdestotrotz einundvierzig Prozent der Bevölkerung hat jetzt die erste Impfung erhalten. Sechsundzwanzig Komma zwei Prozent haben die zweite Impfung erhalten, also schon mal mehr als ein Viertel und ein Fünftel.
Zwanzig Prozent hat die zweite Impfung vor zwei Wochen erhalten.
Das erwähne ich, weil wir davon ausgehen können,
dass sozusagen die maximale Wirkung des Impfstoffs in zwei Wochen nach der zweiten Impfung sich eingestellt haben sollte und sprich, wir haben's jetzt mit dem Land zu tun, wo ein Fünftel,
quasi immunisiert sein sollte, zuzüglich all derer, die bisher schon mal Korona hatten.
Das ist dann zwar nicht ganz so effizient wie die Impfung, aber eine gewisse Immunität bleibt ja auch davon übrig.
Und wir nähern uns also langsam so einen Bereich, äh wo es äh,
eigentlich Ergebnisse geben müsste. Ich will, ich habe jetzt nicht Herdenimonität gesagt, aber ähm
irgendwann äh erreichen wir halt diesen Punkt, wo man sich eben anschauen muss, so okay, gut, jetzt haben alle entweder mit Impfstoff oder mit dem Virus selbst Kontakt gehabt, jetzt müssen wir da sozusagen auch irgendeine äh Wirkung sehen. Ich gucke nochmal ganz kurz
was bei Israel jetzt nach äh bestätigten Fällen insgesamt eigentlich.
Da ist also Israel hat äh zwei.
Achtzigtausend pro eine Million.
Also ungefähr acht Komma zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung hat eine bestätigte Infektion.
Da kann man nochmal ein bisschen dunkelziffer drauf rechnen. Ich mache mal ganz vorsichtig und runde das mal auf zehn Prozent auf. Das heißt, dreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung sollten in irgendeiner Form schon eine irgendeine Immunität haben.
Also wahrscheinlich kannst du es bedenkenlos Bürgerfaktor zwei.
Also ziemlich sicher sogar, also ich also unter zwei ist unwahrscheinlich.
Ja gut, also dann wir hätten da fünfzehn Prozent vielleicht und sagen wir mal fünfundzwanzig Prozent, die jetzt äh zweite Impfung haben, so in den nächsten Tagen dann sozusagen in die volle Immunität reinkommen, die wahrscheinlich vergleichbar ist mit der
Viruskontakt, Immunität, das heißt, dieses Land ist jetzt so über vierzig Prozent Immunität. Rechnerisch.
Mhm. Ja.
Ja, wir haben schon jetzt mehrfach gesagt, irgendwann müssten da mal Zahlen kommen. Ich habe jetzt diese Woche nix gefunden,
Hab jetzt auch nicht aktiv danach gesucht, aber mir ist jetzt auch nichts äh so direkt ins Auge geschoben worden, das verschieben wir dann mal auf nächste Woche oder übernächste Woche, ich denke mal, da wird's demnächst klingeln.
Also ich habe nur kurz äh äh geguckt. Ich meine, Problem ist ja, Israel ist ja, glaube ich, auch immer noch im Lokdown, äh wenn ich das richtig,
sehe so, dass natürlich die Zahlen auch so durch den durch den Logdown dort sinken im Moment und wenn das äh.
Ja aber wenn man das versucht auseinander zu halten und das sind so die Rechnungen die ihr jetzt immer im Netz,
kursieren, so vor allem die Betrachtung, so einmal mit den früh geimpften oder spätgeimpften oder dann die Betrachtung äh dann dann auch,
der Insidenzen jetzt bei Älteren und äh da kann man sagen
macht sich das bei den Älteren jetzt langsam bemerkbar. Ist jetzt noch nicht super dramatisch, äh sage ich mal, bei der das kann man schon sehen. Also man kann,
schon sehen, dass der Impfstoff wirkt, aber sie sind noch nicht an dem Punkt, wo äh die Zahlen ohne Logdowns zurück.
Durch die Impfung. Also da sind sie noch lange nicht. Ja, das ist dann auch noch nicht unbedingt ähm naja gut, Herdenimonität ja.
Wäre das äh im Prinzip aber äh ob die erreicht wird oder jemals erreicht wird, das ist.
Noch komplett offen, weil ähm.
Und so weiter.
Bei den Motationen also rein,
rechnerisch äh bei den Montationen ist zwar ungefähr achtzig Prozent äh Immunität erreichen bei den neuen Montationen in der Bevölkerung damit,
ohne weitere Maßnahmen äh die Zahlen runtergehen.
Soweit ich das gesehen habe, ist zumindest die südafrikanische Mutter zu Israel noch nicht, sondern nicht verbreitet, also von daher sollte zumindest alles das, was da verimpft wird, auch äh Wirkung haben gegen das, was derzeit auch im Umlauf ist,
Da schauen wir gleich nochmal drauf, wenn wir über die ähm Varianten reden. Jetzt würde ich vorschlagen, machen wir nochmal einen kurzen Blick äh nach Europa und die Welt, was so gibt's denn irgendwelche Länder, die.
Sagen wir mal unsere Aufmerksamkeit verdienen.
Na ja, Tschechien natürlich immer erstens weil's eine nahes Nachbarland ist und äh weil ich da geboren bin und überhaupt.
Ähm und weil äh sie irgendwie einen mal wieder eine ganz spezielle, tschechische Art haben mit dem,
um äh zu gehen. Wir haben ja die erste Welle irgendwie perfekt gemeistert so schnell und.
Welle sieht man gar nicht, dafür haben sie dann waren sie dann bei der zweiten Welle so unvorsichtig, dass sie ja,
quasi Rekorde aufgestellt haben und weil in zwei Wellen noch nicht gereicht haben, haben sie dann sich entschlossen, jetzt gleich die dritte Welle äh aufzumachen.
Und ja das ist die Situation in Tschechien.
Willst, wenn sie Pech haben, sind sie auch schon wieder auf dem Weg zur zur nächsten Welle. Derzeit gehen die Zahlen auch gerade wieder hoch.
Also die Zahlen äh wie gesagt, also sie sind schon äh ziemlich weit oben und äh ja, die ziehen halt äh.
Aber das wäre dann schon die vierte Welle, ne? Also.
Ja die ja in ja du hast Recht sie haben schon die dritte Welle hinter sich und machen jetzt 'ne vierte Welle auf.
Das hat so einen Spaß gemacht. Ja, das sind so Kowit-Surf, also das die nehmen eine Welle nach der anderen.
Alle anderen haben's ganz gut in den Griff bekommen, auch Portugal war ja stark betroffen, da fallen die Zahlen gerade massiv, also sie haben so einen richtig geilen R.
Ähm auch
Frankreich muckelt so ein bisschen rum, äh USA fällt stark, Belgien hält sich niedrig. Österreich kriegt die Zahlen zurückgedrückt, also
insgesamt verbessert sich derzeit die Situation im Wesentlichen überall mit wenigen Ausnahmen.
Sogar auch UK, äh ist glaube ich ganz ganz gut äh dabei.
Auch sogar mittlerweile ja, wenn er deutlich mit einer deutlich niedrigeren, positiven Rate.
Als Deutschland Guditisten natürlich auch auch alle deutlich mehr, aber ja hm.
Dann schauen wir doch mal ein bisschen jetzt in die äh in unsere Zukunft. Wie vorhin schon angedeutet, Maßnahmen
werden jetzt zurückgefahren,
und es gab diese Woche mal wieder so ein unsägliches Treffen zwischen Bundesregierung und Ministerpräsidentinnen und
ja das Ergebnis war wie immer ein Kompromiss und Kompromiss, das wissen wir schon, ne? Wie lautet ein schönes Zitat in
Krise und höchster Not ist der Mittelweg der Tod, das fanden sie dann super. Habe ich gedacht, da machen wir doch einen Mittelweg,
und es ist jetzt sozusagen freigegeben worden für die Länder zu entscheiden,
ob sie den Grundschulen und Kitas öffnen wollen und dann geht's irgendwie in Sachsen dann auch gleich mal am fünfzehnten Februar schon los. Andere Länder wie Berlin äh wollen zumindest mal nochmal eine Woche länger warten,
Was sollen wir dazu noch sagen? Also es ist äh.
Eingangs. Die Botschaft an sich ist jetzt schon das Problem und danach ist auch noch die Öffnung als solche ein Problem.
Ja, ich verstehe es nicht. Hamburg ist glaube ich im Moment äh das einzige Land, von dem ich gehört habe, dass äh die die Schulen zulassen.
So
Anderen weiß ich nicht, also die meisten haben sich jetzt irgendwie auf den zweiundzwanzigsten versteift für aber ja irgendwelche vorsichtigen Teilöffnungen, ich glaube teilweise nur Grundschulen.
Ja Grundschulen, halbe Klassen.
Masten und so. Das ist ja auch alles okay und ich meine, das ist das totale Minimum. Nur es ist halt äh Leute wartet doch einfach, bis sie,
bis die Zahlen wirklich unten sind und nicht, dass man anfängt zu hoffen, dass sie irgendwann unten sein könnten. Das ist eigentlich das, was mich am meisten stört.
Und ich muss auch sagen, also Schulunterricht mit Maske, also ganze Zeit im Unterricht. Ich meine.
Das hat doch einen Schulunterricht nicht mehr viel zu tun. So, das ist doch ja, also.
Mein, wo die meisten Leute nach drei Minuten mit Maske im Supermarkt schon eine Krise äh kriegen, äh wollen die da ernsthaft äh ja Kinder,
einen halben Tag mit Maske rumsitzen lassen, ne? Ich meine gut mit OP Maske geht's so.
Aber FFP kannst du knicken in der Schule.
Das geht überhaupt nicht.
So, ja? Also insofern äh so, weil FFP nochmal äh Höchsttragedauer fünfundsiebzig Minuten,
und dann äh dreißig Minuten mindestens äh Erholung, Mindesterholungszeit äh ja ist das, was,
so arbeitsrechtlich die Berufsgenossenschaft vorschreibt. Klar, du stirbst jetzt nicht,
Nach fünfundsiebzig Minuten. Die meisten Leute können wahrscheinlich auch problemlos das Ding den ganzen Tag äh tragen, aber ganz viele eben auch nicht. So.
Ähm,
Das ist das ist das Ding und natürlich man weiß gar nicht, wie es im Moment in Zügen oder Flügen ist. Gibt's da eigentlich FFP zwei Pflicht oder nicht? Ich vermute.
Das weiß ich nicht. Kein, kein Flughafen mehr. Ich habe, ich habe keinen Zug mehr gesehen seit.
Mhm. Danke.
Ewig ewigen Zeiten. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ach ja, vielleicht noch eine Sache, hm, die ich halt äh.
Auch aus diesem, ja, äh wo ich über den Corona Schutzfaktor äh geschrieben habe, habe ich außerdem dazu.
Noch äh so das mit den Attackrates kombiniert, sprich wie viele äh Kontakte, welcher Art äh brauchst du im Schnitt äh um.
Jemanden anzustecken, ja? Gut geht's ein bisschen in beide Richtungen, aber,
und da ist es so, dass je nach Virus und Alter sind so zwischen zehn und
und und Art des Kontakts äh sind so zwischen ähm zehn und zwanzig Kontakte im Schnitt, die zu einer Infektion führen,
ungeschützt, ja? Äh und Kontakt heißt dann sowas, also.
Es gibt da so verschiedene Kontaktklassen, so wie es in England.
Klassifiziert wird, gut bei uns wird's das in ähnlicher Form äh auch geben. Fand das aber ein bisschen schicker, wie die Engländer.
Machen, das heißt äh.
Du hast halt zwei Arten von Kontakten üblicherweise niedriges Risiko, hohes äh Risiko oder äh die Engländer nennen das ähm,
direkt und nah so und direkt ist halt wenn du jemand anfasst, wenn du.
Ein Gespräch führst, Gesichtszugewandt äh und näher als ein Meter,
zusammenstehst und äh wenn du angehustet, angenießt oder angespuckt wirst, so,
Das ist halt ein direkter Kontakt. Und einen Nahkontakt ist so hm entweder.
Weniger als ein Meter nicht Gesichtszugewandt, also,
auch mit Rücken zueinander, aber ein Meter äh oder ein bis zwei Meter äh jeweils für dann mindestens fünfzehn Minuten. Ähm.
Ja plus noch so ein paar äh oder im im äh im gemeinsamen PKW äh äh fahren oder halt im Zuchtbus äh.
Flugzeug.
Dann äh ja wenn man das in der Kombination genau mindestens auch fünfzehn Minuten äh.
Dann neben jemanden sitzen, der äh ja infiziert ist. Also.
Und der der Punkt ist mit Masken kann man halt diese Zeit und in Maskenkombination eben entsprechend verlängern. Also und.
Das Ergebnis ist, dass.
Die Kombination aus Masken und Abstand äh tatsächlich funktioniert. Aber nur Maske oder nur Abstand äh.
Reicht einfach nicht, weil nicht nicht in Zügen und ähm.
Da sagen, war der, war der Punkt, dass wenn jemand.
Neben dir sitzt direkt im Zug oder im im Flieger und der hat halt B eins eins sieben und.
Beide äh äh haben.
So, dann äh und ähm dann hast du nach ein paar Stunden bist du trotzdem infiziert.
Das äh sagen halt die Rechnungen. Was funktioniert ist oder was ziemlich sicher ist, ist die Kombination Maske und zwei Meter Abstand.
Ein bis zwei Meter ist ein und Maske ist ist auch schon okay, aber äh eigentlich darfst du selbst mit Maske äh äh unter ein Meter äh für längere Zeit ähm ja,
funktioniert nicht.
Ja gut, also wir sind uns auf jeden Fall einig, äh, dass mir die Schulöffnung ist ein Risiko und das größte Problem dabei ist, ist gar nicht mal die Schulöffnung selber, sondern das Problem ist einfach,
Die Tatsache, dass sie angekündigt wurden und dass man jetzt befürchten muss, dass Leute wieder denken, och na dann äh ist doch alles gut, aber ist halt nicht alles gut, wie wir vorhin ja ausführlich dargelegt haben.
Vielleicht mal ein ganz kurzer Blick nach Australien, nur mal so zu gucken, wie wie die sich so schlagen. Also die haben ja äh quasi Zerokovic.
Allerdings haben sie auch internationalen Verkehr, das heißt, es passiert dann doch immer mal wieder was. Jetzt ist zum Beispiel in Viktoria, also ein Teil Australiens ist so die UK-Variante aufgetaucht.
Ergebnis sofort fünf Tage komplett lockdown verordnet. Ja, also ist einfach so.
Da ist was aufgetaucht. Leute äh alles äh alles verboten. Also nur einkaufen.
Und Ausnahme für ähm also wie sie es nennen, Care und Care Geving, also ich vermute mal,
in irgendeiner Form medizinische Betreuung, Central Worker natürlich und äh Sport darf man noch machen, aber das war's dann auch. Du darfst dich auch nicht weiter als fünf Kilometer wegbewegen jetzt für Laufen und einkaufen.
Alle müssen Masten tragen, keine Besucher zu Hause, also auch nicht so ein Unsinn mit irgendwie ja, nur so und so viele Mitglieder von anderen Haushalten und so weiter, nee, einfach so zack, bleibt einfach zu Hause. Zu den Laden, fünf Tage.
Schulen dicht, Ausbildungsstätten, dicht, Wunnies, dicht.
Öffentliche Versammlung verboten von der Zuhause arbeiten, keine Hochzeiten, keine Kirchen, Beerdigung, ja mit zehn Leuten, alle internationalen Flüge mussten gleich wieder umdrehen. Ähm ne, also,
keine keine keine also also nicht die Flüge mussten umdrehen, sondern die, die in Transit waren,
durften nicht weiter fliegen, also es ist sozusagen einfach Shutta und Shotda und Shotdan in äh Melbourne. Ja, so und so kriegen sie's halt.
In der Regel auch im Griff, das hitzt sich das erste Mal, dass das passiert ist, sondern so machen sie es halt einfach in dem Moment, wo irgendwie eine Fliege ist.
Wird nicht die Fliegenplatsche rausgeholt und geguckt, ob vielleicht mal irgendwo eine zu sehen ist. Sondern es wird halt einfach.
Der ganze Raum.
Der,
Genau. Da kommt dann einfach äh Strahlung an den Start und es wird einfach alles so lange ausgedünstet, bis da irgendwie nichts mehr fliegt.
Denn das Virus bleibt gefährlich ähm
Hörte ja vorhin schon angedeutet, dass man nochmal ein bisschen über diese Varianten sprechen. Dazu gibt's eine interessante Ressource, auf die ich hingewiesen wurde, die ist äh heißt Co-Varianz Punkt org und das ist eine Arbeit von ähm einer Person, die auch
auf Twitter schon aufgefallen ist immer Hot Croft.
Äh an der Universität äh Universität Bern ist die unterwegs und ähm die twittert schon äh
Ja, sehr viel zum Thema mit den ganzen Mutationen et cetera. Also wer so richtig da im Nordmodus unterwegs sein möchte, das auf jeden Fall so eine Person, der man da folgen möchte,
Firefox sechs sechs. Nee, warte mal, war das ein X oder,
Äh
Zwei Echse.
Zwei zwei.
Steht jedenfalls.
Ja genau, Feuer, Fox B zwei, äh, Xen und zwei Sächsen,
Genau. Und ähm ja, Co-Varianz dot org und das ist ganz interessant, weil hier sieht man nämlich auf der einen Seite die konkreten Mutationen, die aufgetreten sind.
In dieser ähm Notation, die wir ja jetzt schon äh mehrfach ähm gesehen haben, die ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig durchdrungen habe,
aber zum Beispiel die äh extrem populäre Mutation ähm N fünf null eins.
Die ist wohl in verschiedenen Varianten wiederum gibt, also ich glaube es.
Die N fünf null eins Y. Das ist sozusagen die, die am meisten ist, das bedeutet ja immer an der Stelle fünfhunderteins auf dieser genetischen Information.
Ist halt äh ein eine Aminosäure vom Typ N auf den Typ Y gewechselt. Das heißt das letzten Endes,
Und all so diese ganzen Varianten, die so derzeit im Umlauf sind und das sind nochmal mehr als man normalerweise so liest,
die sind halt hier aufgeführt und man kann sich dann eben einerseits genau anschauen,
Okay, was weiß man darüber überhaupt, in in welchen Varianten ist diese Mutation aufgetreten und dann eben auch in welchem Land ist sie, wie stark vertreten nach dem, was man weiß,
dazu noch so ein Proteinmodell, wo man dann genau sehen kann, wo diese Motationen eigentlich greifen.
Ja und das alles äh schön klickbar und man kann sich das halt sowohl nach Varianten äh äh anschauen. Man kann sich das aber auch so nach Ländern,
anschauen und dadurch relativ schnell einen Überblick kriegen und ich hatte ja vorhin gesagt, so Israel und so, na ja, da ist halt irgendwie die Variante unterwegs,
Das weiß ich wegen dieser Webseite, ne? Also zum Beispiel lässt sich da ganz klar herauslesen, dass eben so Ende November diese fünf null eins Variante, die ja auch äh England erfasst hat, da also steil nach oben gegangen ist und äh,
derzeit den den Großteil ausmacht und andere Länder äh alles anders. Könnt ihr selber mal durchklicken ist auf jeden Fall ähm.
Ganz schön, ne? Auch diese E vier acht vier K Geschichte ähm die.
Aus Südafrika kommt, die lässt sich da halt auch entsprechend nachschlagen.
Ja, damit äh kommen wir dann vielleicht auch mal ähm nach Südafrika.
Denn Südafrika hat ja eben genau diese ähm B eins drei fünf eins äh strain
eben wo diese E vier acht vier K Mutation eine große Rolle spielt und da gab's ja jetzt den Fall, die hatten ja gerade Lieferungen bekommen von dem ähm,
Astra Sinika, Ochsford, äh, im Stoff.
Waren eigentlich drauf und dann das zu verimpfen, aber dann gab's jetzt erste Ergebnisse, dass dieser Impfstoff gegen die südafrikanische Variante ähm nur sehr schlechte Ergebnisse erzielt hat.
Bisschen Angst hat, äh, wenn man jetzt loslegt und das Pflegepersonal damit impft, dass es am Ende überhaupt nichts bringt der ganze Aufwand.
Also so wie ich das wahrgenommen habe gilt das nicht unbedingt jetzt so aus als ausgemacht, dass diese ersten Ergebnisse unbedingt das auch,
das ist sozusagen nichts hilft, aber das wird auf jeden Fall ganz interessant sein, das zu verfolgen. Derzeit scheint auf jeden Fall diese Südafrika Variante, die größte Bedrohung in diesem ganzen Spiel zu sein.
Mhm.
Wobei ich irgendwie gut in einer nur so mittelseriösen Zeitschrift, ich glaube, das war der Fokus.
Offenen,
Artikel heute gestoßen bin, äh glaube ich, wo dann von einer Horror äh äh neuen Horrorvariante äh aus dem Amazonas berichtet wurde, die nochmal irgendwie,
drei oder vier Mal so ansteckend äh sein soll wie Korona Classi.
Äh ja, ich also.
Bestätigung, äh seriöse Bestätigung dafür habe ich jetzt noch nicht gefunden äh aber werde ich mir mal werde ich auch mal nachgehen, ob da irgendwas im Busch,
ist aber äh ja.
Seite gefällt mir wirklich sehr gut muss ich sagen.
Ist wirklich nett, ich gucke gerade mal.
Okay, ich gucke gerade, was denn bei uns jetzt die eigentlich der äh der verbreitete also wir haben zwanzig Prozent zwanzig A EU eins. Irgendwie.
Was glaube ich sozusagen hier was glaube ich so dieser Wildtyp ist, ne? Also was sozusagen einfach das ist, was wir hier normalerweise haben. Also ich,
Ich bin jetzt noch nicht in der Lage aus dieser Webseite viel hier rauszulesen. Ich wollte das nur mal darauf hinweisen, dass es diese Webseite,
und dass sie unter Umständen nochmal eine ganz brauchbare Ressource sein kann, wenn's darum geht, hier Muttertionsjagd zu machen. Jagd, den Mutanten.
Ja aber laut dessen haben wir bereits das richtig sehe ja ein Drittel.
Zweiunddreißig Prozent, ich meine, die haben hier Distribution pur Country ist ja immer halt schon bei dreißig Prozent im Moment.
Bei der äh SN fünf null eins Montation.
Ja, es geht auf jeden Fall äh voran. Das hatten wir ja letztes Mal auch schon berichtet. Also wir haben jetzt da keine, ich habe jetzt zumindest keine genaueren neuen Zahlen. Ich denke mal, da werden wir demnächst was davon hören, wie sich das äh in Deutschland so verbreitet.
Aber das Ding ist da und das äh wird kommen. Also.
Können wir hoffen, wie wir wollen. Ich habe die Zahlen, die jetzt hier ähm
gegeben sind in diesen Ländern vergleichen noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden. Hier ist nicht so von Prozenten die Rede, sondern von Frequency und ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wie ich das übersetzen soll. Das muss ich irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen,
bisschen reinlesen.
Na ja, häufig, also ich glaube, äh das kann man schon so lieben, meine süßen Werte zwischen null und eins.
Ich würde einfach mal von,
ausgehen, dass das quasi der Prozentsatz beziehungsweise der der mal hundert äh Hunden ähm dessen ist, in wie viel der sequenzierten Proben man diese Mutation gefunden hat.
Also zum Beispiel SN fünf null eins ist halt mit null Komma acht fünf, also fünfundachtzig Prozent in Südafrika.
Beispielsweise. Gut, das hängt natürlich auch immer davon ab, wie viel sequenziert ist äh und so, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht äh.
Da in fünf null eins ist ja nur eine Mutation. Das ist ja nicht die Variante, ja.
Bär, nein. Da ist schon.
So, das heißt, es kann sich nicht okay, also du meinst, es ist sozusagen prozentualer Anteil, mag sein,
will jetzt noch keine finale Aussage zu machen, bevor ich das nicht vollständig verstanden habe. Dafür misst es jetzt, habe ich damit noch nicht genug gearbeitet, bevor ich hier in irgendwelche Fehlinterpretationen reinlaufe.
Ja, wollen wir dann nochmal auf einen umfangreicheren Bereich kommen,
du hast dich da ja auch ein bisschen reingelesen, ich auch gab da einen sehr interessanten Blogpost zum Thema
Produktion der MRNA, Impfstoffe und wo hängt's denn eigentlich dran, dass hier nicht so viel da ist, wie man vielleicht gerne hätte,
Das ist äh von Jonas Neubert auf seinem Blog äh ein wirklich länglicher Blogpost mit äh viel Text,
und viel links
ich hab den so zu na ja vier Fünftel irgendwie durchgelesen und bin vielen Dings noch nicht so richtig gefolgt. Du hast es dir glaub ich komplett durchgelesen ne?
Es gibt eine sehr schöne Übersetzung davon, von Noah Leidinger, wiederum auf seinem Blog. Das ist äh jemand, der englisch und deutsch spricht, was nicht, ob der aus Deutschland kommt, denkbar. Aber ich glaube, nee, der kommt, glaube ich, aus Österreich, weil der schreibt Jena,
Ähm statt Januar deutliches Zeichen. Ja.
Was hast du äh davon mitgenommen? Also ähm der Blogpost beschreibt ja erstmal relativ ausführlich, was.
Muss eigentlich alles zusammenkommen für so einen Impfstoff. Man redet ja immer sehr viel über RNA und wie das so wirkt, aber das ist ja letzten Endes kein Impfstoff, sondern das ist ja eigentlich nur der Wirkstoff. Aber ein Impfstoff muss ja nun,
mehrere Dinge zusammenbringen und nicht nur am Ende das Richtige tun, sondern vor allem erstmal in der Lage sein, zu diesem Ende überhaupt zu kommen. Also in der Zelle äh den Bauplan zu verteilen, damit diese Proteine dann produziert werden, diese Spike-Proteine produziert werden, um die,
Antikörperreaktionen ähm auszulösen.
Genau. Also
Ich meine, das haben wir ja bei allen Medikamenten hat man halt die Wirkstoffe und dann alle möglichen Hilfsstoffe, also in Tabletten halt irgendein äh äh Pulver, äh was dann zusammengepresst wird, was dann halt
keine Wirkung hat, sondern versorgt, dass sich das dann im Magen auflöst, aber äh wirken äh tut das halt nicht und das haben wir halt bei Impfstoffen.
Auch und.
Ja bei den M RNA-Impfstoffen haben wir halt den diese beiden äh RNA-Varianten. Einmal von Fiser und einmal die von Moderner.
Und dann.
Einer der wichtigsten Hilfsstoffe ist halt diese Lipidhülle, diese Fetthülle in die dieser Wirkstoff dann reinkommt.
Und die besteht halt äh aus einer Reihe von äh ziemlich ja,
ähm also du zum einen cholesterin, aber dann eben äh äh halt auch noch eine ganze Reihe von,
Lipiden,
mit äh so äh Namen wie eins zwei Dimirisol, Glycero drei, Metoxi Pulli it,
Tylen Glykol zweitausend ähm so ja ähm.
DMG-Pick zweitausend für Leute, die Abkürzung drauf haben. Ja, ist super, ne?
Ja, ja. Und ähm ja dann.
Jetzt äh halt noch die Stoffe, die halt den den Puffer äh äh bilden, also Puffer. In der Chemine sind halt so Substanzen, die helfen äh den PH-Wert einfach zu
stabilisieren. So, wenn du das Zeugs äh drin hast, dann äh macht das je nachdem äh die,
Lösung äh ähm saurer oder,
alkalischer und äh so hält damit den den PH-Wert eben äh konstant, ne? Und dazu ja,
das sind halt aber überwiegend alles mögliche Alltagsstoffe, also es ist jetzt auch kein Problem, außerdem ist sie interessant fand,
in beiden Impfstoffen noch Zucker drin, also so große ähm ja und äh.
So wie es aussieht, wenn man jetzt guckt, okay, wo kommen die her die ganzen Sachen, dann gibt es da schon unterschiedliche Lieferketten, also erstmal muss man auch sagen, äh moderner und.
Pfeiser haben sehr verschiedene ähm Lieferketten und,
manches gesehen habe, ist die äh hat Pfeil Sabiontech
zwei verschiedene Liefer oder Produktionsketten eine für die USA und eine für Europa und die sind nicht wirklich
allzu sehr miteinander verbunden. Die also es was in den USA produziert wird, bleibt in den USA und äh was in Europa produziert wird.
In Europa oder in in anderen Ländern. Ja und ähm.
So der RNA-Herstellungsprozess scheint.
Mittlerweile ja äh ganz äh,
bekannt äh zu sein. Ich meine, da muss man halt erstmal,
DNA produzieren. Äh die wird dann äh in äh Kolibakterien, also im Prinzi.
Darmbakterien ein,
geschleust und dann produzieren diese Bakterien halt die DNA. So das Ganze muss dann halt.
Rausgeholt werden, also ständig irgendwelche ja, Filter und Extraktions.
Prozesse ähm so plus äh dass äh noch so
Trick passieren muss, weil äh sich quasi die M RNA, wenn man die nur so nackt drin lässt
sich halt so ein bisschen aufdröselt und deswegen gibt's da noch sogenannte PolyA-Schwänze am Ende, äh die dafür sorgen, äh ja.
Dass das Ende dann eben auch stabil ist und dass da nichts abfällt.
Ja, das ist jetzt im Prinzip zwei äh zwei Schritte ein bisschen zusammengeworfen, um mal kurz klarzumachen, also man fängt mit DNA an.
Produziert die quasi mit so einem DNA-Drucker in äh kleinen Mengen, dann gibt man das in diese Bakterien, diese Bakterien erzeugen dann größere Mengen an DNA,
und damit macht man dann erst die RNA und das ist ja dann sozusagen nochmal so ein zweiter Vorgang, das heißt, dann nimmt man diese Polymerasen, die äh Proteine, die dann halt einfach äh von diesem DNA äh RNA erzeugen.
Und außerdem genau und aussehen, das hatten wir auch schon mal äh erwähnt, damit äh man das Immunsystem äh so ein bisschen äh.
Umgeht oder oder sorgt, dass das sagen die RNA nicht vom Immunsystem angegriffen wird haben sie ein Buchstaben also in Orazil in der in der RNA Sequenz halt.
Durch einen anderen Stoff ja Pseudo-Eridul, glaube ich, Eridly.
Ja auch als N eins mit Typ Pseudoridin bekann.
Kennt man. Kennt man.
Und aber Pseudoridul nicht mit dem bekannteren Pseudo Pseudoridin verwechseln. Die klingen jetzt äh ähnlich ja.
Die Dödel Dü.
Genau.
Dirien, düdel, du. Genau, wir hatten das alles schon vor
zwei, drei Sendungen, als wir diesen anderen schönen Blogpost erwähnt haben, wo diese ganze Dekodierung des äh des eigentlichen Impfimpfstoffs mal diskutiert wurde. Da haben wir diese ganzen Sachen erklärt. Das sind natürlich jetzt Sachen, die müssen hier auch alle berücksichtigt werden und das
Problem dabei ist, dass man jetzt eben diese ganzen Stoffe auch sourcen muss. Und in diesem Artikel werden einfach wirklich die unterschiedlichsten Quellen genannt, also das sind dann eben nicht Länder, sondern das sind einfach,
spezifische einzelne Firmen, die das irgendwie weltweit teilweise alleine überhaupt stemmen. Also wo es einfach mal von bestimmten
gibt's einfach mal nur ein oder zwei Hersteller, die das überhaupt in nennenswerten Mengen als ähm Ausgangsstoff, als Hilfsstoff für die Medizin anbieten,
die sind teilweise in der Schweiz und teilweise in Deutschland, teilweise in USA, teilweise in Kamera, es geht quer über den ganzen Planeten, aber im wesentlichen spielt sich das in USA und Europa ab.
Genau, also es ist also die Lieferkette ist äh erstaunlich komplex äh und ähm ja bei den äh genau, also vielleicht ja.
Die Erzeugung von diesem RNA, die ist also ist komplex, aber ist ein gelöstes Problem. Es ist jetzt nicht so das Problem, die nennenswerten Mengen an RNA zu
erzeugen. Das hat man raus. Das Problem ist, damit es eben ein Impfstoff wird, müssen eben die anderen genannten Beimengungen eben,
in der richtigen Kombination im richtigen Prozess, in der richtigen Geschwindigkeit zusammengeführt werden, also dieser Puffer und der Zucker, aber vor allem eben diese Lipid
Also diese Fettsäuren, die letzten Endes so als Nanopartikel dieses RNA ja umschließen sollen, weil nur dann
kann es sich überhaupt erstmal stabil in so einem Impfstoff äh halten, kann dann in die Blutbahn
geraten und zu den Zellen transportiert werden, diese Fetthülle ist ein Schutz nach außen. Der Zucker dabei ist ein Schutz vor dem Gefrieren, das Gefrieren selber ist ja Schutz vor Verfall und wenn es dann im Körper ist, dann ist äh diese Fetthülle
auch quasi der Gateway in die Zelle. Dadurch kann es in diese Zelle eintauchen, entlässt dort die RNA,
und dann kann der Impfstoff erst seine volle Wirkung erzielen. Und das Problem bei der Produktion stellt sich jetzt raus, so kann man das sehr schön aus diesem Blogartikel herauslesen, ist tatsächlich dieses einschließende RMA.
In diese Fetthülle, denn da das nun mal keine Technik ist, die wir schon seit zwanzig Jahren machen, gibt's dafür auch,
eigentlich.
Keine Technik, also es gibt zumindest keine massenhaft verfügbare seit Jahren, abgehangene Technik, die das in einem industriellen Maßstab durchführen kann, so wie wir es jetzt eigentlich bräuchten, sondern
Das ist halt eher so na ja, wenn man jetzt hier so zehn verschiedene Laborgeräte nebeneinander stecken und die miteinander richtig verbinden, dann tut es das, was wir brauchen.
Ja und wurde auch ein Hersteller erwähnt, der im Prinzip schon mal ähm sowas als Maschine gebaut hat, der aber wohl derzeit in dieser Produktionskette auch noch keine Rolle spielt.
Mikro, wie heißt das? Mikrofluidität, also sozusagen diese,
Steuerung kleinster Mengen von Inhaltsstoffen, die eben zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in den richtigen Druck, in der richtigen Menge, in der richtigen Flusssteuerung zusammengeführt werden,
damit dann eben diese biochemischen Prozesse am Ende auch genauso stattfinden wie man sie braucht.
Also mit anderen Worten, es ist nicht so, also diese diese Einhüllung in die Fetthülle ist nicht so, dass man einfach die Stoffe äh vermischen und dann.
Umrühren muss und dann entsteht das halt schon, sondern äh ja das ist quasi wirklich mehr so
dass da vielleicht nicht Molekül für Molekül aber mit wirklich kleinsten Mengen
mit eben ja, weil das sind nun mal Nanopartikel äh so ähm und,
muss ich das halt vorstellen, dass diese Mikrofluidik äh,
Dinger kann man sich vorstellen ist halt ja Kunststoff oder Glas oder irgendein ein Träger und da sind dann halt,
üblicherweise dann ultra feine Kanäle drin und ja außerdem gibt's dann.
So verschiedene Ventile beziehungsweise Steuerelemente. Da gibt's halt auch total abgefahrene äh Sachen,
glaube.
Zum Beispiel äh es es gibt halt äh in der nicht nur in der Mikrofluidik, äh ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst. Es äh einen einen Ventil ohne bewegliche Teile.
Und das funktioniert äh halt ähm im Prinzip so, dass da die Strömungen aufgeteilt und auf sich selbst äh.
Ah ja, äh das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
So 'ne Diode so.
Aussparung, ne?
Genau, in einer Richtung sozusagen in einer Richtung fließt es, aber in der Gegenrichtung äh werden
halt die Ströme so verwirbelt beziehungsweise gegen sich selbst gelenkt, dass du einen extrem hohen Durchfluss Widerstand hast und je nachdem wie viel du davon hintereinander kaskadierst, hast du dann
am Ende quasi ein Ventil ohne bewegliche Teile, wo,
Zeugs nur in einer Richtung durchfließen kann, aber nicht in der anderen Richtung und sowas äh ja hat man da,
und ja, wie du so richtig,
sagt, das ist alles noch nicht so richtig äh ja für die, für die Großproduktion äh äh bisher geeignet, sondern überwiegend.
Laborequipment oder Kleinserienequipment und
wirklich interessieren, wie viel von den Geräten, äh, die da so jetzt rumstehen haben, wie viel von den kleinen Geräten, aber das scheint jedenfalls wohl gerade ähm
ja der Flaschenhals zu sein.
Genau, das ist ein Problem und das kann man sich natürlich auch schnell vorstellen, weil diesen Bedarf gab's vor einem Jahr nicht. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht gerade unbedingt die Art von Technologie,
Wo jetzt so ein kleines Unternehmen, was vielleicht
was ich vielleicht derzeit im Bereich Stückzahlen von fünfzig Stück pro Jahr produziert hat, wenn's hochkommt, die können jetzt auch nicht mal eben das äh hochdrehen. Und was der Artikel ja auch noch erwähnt und das ist ja auch noch ein wichtiger Faktor.
Der Artikel meinte, es gäbe nur eine kleine, dreistellige Zahl von Leuten, die diese Technologie einfach überhaupt checken.
Also die die sozusagen als Fachpersonal hier überhaupt, also weltweit in Frage kommen. So, das ist einfach ein Bereich.
So hochspezialisiert war, aber jetzt eben auf einmal total,
im im Mittelpunkt des Geschehens äh steht, dass der eben mal nicht so ohne weiteres hochgedreht werden kann. Ich meine, wir hatten ja diese Debatte auch schon und die läuft ja auch immer wieder auf allen Kanälen. Ich glaube, wir hatten das auch in der im Feedback,
kam das auch mit auf,
so diese Erwartungshaltung, warum wird er nicht mehr produziert? Und warum kann man denn nicht irgendwie das hochdrehen? Und du hattest das ja hier auch.
Auch zu als Frage in den Raum gestellt, ne? Vor zwei Ausgaben so dieses Jahr, ich verstehe nicht, warum die da jetzt irgendwelche Einschränkungen haben und warum müssen die denn irgendwie was runterfahren, um irgendwas hochzufahren und so äh,
Das ist jetzt keine unmittelbare direkte Antwort auf diese Frage,
Aber es ist offensichtlich, dass wir es hier einfach mit noch eine relativ ragilen Gesamtlösung zu tun haben. Und wenn ich mal so ein bisschen Softwareanalogie.
Mit reinbringen darf. Du kennst das, man entwickelt da irgendwas, dann baut man sich so einen Prototypen zusammen und dann hat man so zwei, drei,
Na ja, Teile in diesem System,
die so für den Prototypen ganz okay funktioniert haben oder eine Woche später äh rauscht dann so äh äh die Geschäftsführung rein, sagt das ist ja total super, was wir hier gesehen haben. Das installieren wir jetzt mal beim Kunden und der hat hier irgendwie hundert Filialen und denkst schon so, oh mein Gott
wenn wir das hochskalieren, dann bricht das alles auseinander,
und so ein bisschen ähm habe ich so den Eindruck, äh so eine Gefahr besteht halt hier oder beziehungsweise an dem Moment ist es halt auch einfach nicht ohne weiteres skalierbar. Ich bin mir sicher, da wird skaliert werden. Das ist mit Sicherheit auch ein Bereich, der sagen wir mal,
Mit ein paar Monaten oder einem Jahr Anlaufzeit zu neuen Höhen sich aufschwingen können wird, mal diese Technik natürlich nachgefragt ist, da ist eine Menge Geld zu verdienen. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so.
Dass man sagen kann super, der Impfstoff ist erfunden. Jetzt gib doch mal den Bauplan frei.
So gibt unsere so nachdem ihr jetzt jahrelang auf eigene Gefahr auf ein zwar mit ein paar Investoren im im Rücken, aber im Prinzip sozusagen ins,
Unklare hinein geforscht habt
Ja und das ganze Risiko dafür betragen habt und vielleicht die einzigen auf der Welt waren, die daran geglaubt haben, jetzt wo wir wissen, dass wir das total äh brauchen, dann nehmen wir euch das mal ganz gerne aus der Hand, damit das jetzt überall produziert werden kann.
Und das finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen falsch und man merkt aber auch, äh dass wir in diesem Artikel auch klar das ist jetzt nicht so, dass es so eine Horika-Erfindung ist.
Und die kann man jetzt einfach nehmen und kopieren und dann funktioniert das aus den genannten Gründen. Es gibt nicht genug Personal. Es sind diese Technik existiert noch gar nicht. Schon gar nicht für Unternehmen, die bisher in diesem Segment noch überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung haben. Und ähm.
Du brauchst das Know-How und du das ist auch ein Prozess, der weiter verbessert wird. Also ich glaube nicht, dass diese Impfstoffe in einem Jahr auch nur ansatzweise so produziert werden wie jetzt,
Sie werden wahrscheinlich ganz andere Specks haben. Es wird Änderungen geben, also das ist sozusagen noch auf dem Weg sich zu verbessern. Und wenn man jetzt sozusagen äh.
Unerfahrene Unternehmen jetzt hier mit reinbringen, wo sie sagen, das kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin. Äh könnte das halt auch schnell in so ein Desaster führen. Also ich
glaube nicht so richtig daran, dass es ein Punkt ist. Man muss jetzt halt einfach schauen, äh wie man diesen Unternehmen dabei helfen kann, hier diese Produktionskapazitäten aufzubauen,
Die werden immer mal wieder an Probleme stoßen, die werden an Regularien stoßen, die werden dann Finanzierungsprobleme stoßen, die werden äh Verfügbarkeit von von irgendwas äh.
Rohstoff brauchen oder so der einfach sonst nicht verfügbar ist. Da muss man helfen und dann kommen wir auch vorwärts.
Ja äh und einige der Stoffe äh zum Beispiel selbst unter den Lipiden gibt's also,
paar spezielle liepide äh sind halt auch ultra teuer. Äh so äh ein.
Teuer und genau und das wollte ich gerade noch sagen, entschuldige noch die Anmerkung, das hatte ich jetzt gerade äh äh vergessen, darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich hinaus. Also es ist nicht nur so, dass jetzt hier eine Lizenz,
oder so oder von moderner erforderlich wäre, sondern auch die haben wiederum von zahlreichen anderen Unternehmen teilweise Lösungen und äh bestimmte Stoffe lizenziert, die sie dann in Lizenz produzieren. Also.
Das ist eine riesige Kette von Abhängigkeiten, die man nicht mal so eben auflösen kann. Aber es gibt auch teilweise eben auch nur einzelne Hersteller, die das können.
Einige der Moleküle sind patentiert äh.
Ja
Äh ja, waren wir gar nicht so klar, dass es in dem Umfang sozusagen äh ja so ein moderner hat ja dieses firmeneigenes Molekül namens Lipit SM einhundertzwei, aber da hat sich dann wiederum ein anderes Unternehmen, Arobutus, Biopharma
unglaublich klagt dagegen, weil sie meint,
dass sowas bereits patentiert äh zu haben und äh ja plus also sogenannte ja.
Sind alles so kathionische Lipide und eins davon hier kann man bei Organix Ink äh für fünftausend Dollar pro hundert Milligramm, also fünfzigtausend Dollar pro Gramm äh,
werden da für dieses Lepi.
Das goldene Scheiß dagegen, ne?
Ja. Also ich meine es gibt äh in der Chemie gibt's äh äh durchaus so manche Stoffe sogar auch manche Elemente oder so. Äh die irrsinnig teuer sind ähm.
Aber äh ja ich wusste nicht, dass man äh.
Im Prinzip ja, dass man lipide, äh dass die auch so teuer sein können, wenn man ganz äh offenbar ist eben so.
Und interessant in dem Zusammenhang ist auch, dass sich da offenbar.
Irgendwie also Pfeiser und Biontech, diese diese Kombination scheint sich als ganz.
Erfolgreich zu erweisen, was so den Output angeht, weil wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh sind die, was die Produktion angeht äh,
hauen die wesentlich mehr raus als moderner, oder?
Ich glaub moderner liefert vor allem in die USA. Während äh Pfeiser
vorne rein drauf geachtet hat, sich von der amerikanischen Regierung in keinerlei Hinsicht vereinnahmen zu lassen. Die haben da keine Förderkohle genommen, die haben das alles auf eigene Faust gemacht und haben sich auch auf keine bindenden Verträge äh geeinigt
Aufteilung, also im Prinzip teilen die sich die Kohle, die sie dabei gewinnen, Faisa und Biontech,
Ähm Bion Tech hat allerdings, also Pfeiser macht halt die Distruption in den meisten Ländern und vor allem in den USA,
Aber es gibt eine Ausnahme für Biotech, die organisieren das in Deutschland und in der Türkei bin ich überraschend selber,
gibt's nochmal so ein Sonderdeal für China, den habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden. Das ist im Prinzip auch, ob liegt auch irgendwie Bayern Tech, aber die haben das dann irgendwie nochmal an ein anderes chinesisches Unternehmen weiter delegiert, das
noch ein bisschen unklar, wie, wie das so läuft, aber die haben dann relativ komplexes Gebilde, aber so als Partnerstruktur scheint es zumindest gut zu funktionieren.
Ja.
Fazit, ist alles nicht so einfach. People are Working ar net. Es wird besser werden.
Neue Technologie wird geschaffen werden. In wenigen Wochen wird dieses Marburger Produktionszentrum hochgefahren und deutlich mehr.
Wirkstoff, Impfstoff auf den Markt werfen, beziehungsweise nicht auf den Markt, sondern in die die,
bereits abgegebenen Bestellungen äh entsprechende Lieferungen generieren
Und dann ist damit zu rechnen, dass da was passiert, aber ich glaube, jede Vorstellung, dass irgendjemand anders als die Akteure, die da gerade dran sind, da in irgendeiner Form was verbessern können
ist glaube ich ein bisschen fehlgeleitet. Dafür ist dieser ganze technische Bereich noch nicht ähm so weit gemacht,
Wenn das mal so ist wie bei den Vektorimpfstoffen, dass das irgendwie zehn, zwanzig Jahre lang alles erfolgreich ausprobiert wurde und man dafür die entsprechenden Fabriken hat, die das dann in großen Mengen produzieren kann. Super. Aber jetzt müssen hier einfach noch die fundamentalen
Sachen auf der Kette bekommen werden und es in gewisser Hinsicht schon ein Wunder, dass man das jetzt in so kurzer Zeit überhaupt schon auf solche Mengen äh hat kommen können.
Ne, wobei die, ich glaube, die weckt so im Stoffe sind auch noch äh äh relativ.
Relativ neu, aber du kannst glaube ich trotzdem für die die Produktion äh existierende Produktionsanlagen leichter ritrofiten als das jetzt eben bei dieser MRNA-Produktion ist.
Traditionell, ich weiß, wurden äh ähm das nochmal ein Hühnereiern, äh, wurde das glaube ich immer gezüchtet. Früher kann ich mich erinnern, so Impfstoffe, dass da.
Ja was dran.
Aber da wurden wahrscheinlich dann eher nur sozusagen die Urkeime oder die Proteine direkt äh äh dann äh.
Vervielfältigt und dann kleingehackt und gefiltert und äh ja.
Dann gespritzt äh sagen, dass man dann entweder ja Geschwächte Viren äh.
Oder zerstückelte Teile davon halt direkt ins Blut gespritzt kriegt. Da ist natürlich das, was man jetzt sowohl mit Invektoriumsstoffen und mit den MRN AM Stoffen ist natürlich deutlich cleverer.
So und dann sind wir eigentlich auch schon am Ende. Hast du gesehen, dass ähm jetzt tatsächlich eine meiner Vorhersagen,
Forderungen erfüllt wurden, ich meinte ja, alles ganz einfach, wir lösen das Problem im Pflicht für Urlauber nach Mallorca und dann wird sie das schon von alleine lösen. Sieht wohl so aus, als ob Spanien das tatsächlich äh tun wird. Es hei
wenn Malle dann nur mit äh Impfstempel.
Mhm. Ja.
Das ist doch mal wirklich ein überzeugendes Argument. Also wenn die Leute sagen, warum soll ich mich denn impfen? Ich äh bin ja, was weiß ich unter vierzig. Mir kann ja nichts passieren oder was für ein Dusselsige Ausreden die Leute sonst noch so erfinden. Kann man jetzt einfach sagen
Dann gibt's halt auch kein Malle.
Ich mein das Interessante ist ja, dass,
zumindest vom Haustier oder Tiertransport kennen wir das ja schon immer,
halt, wenn du irgendwie dein Hund oder Katze oder so über die Grenze bringen willst, muss das Ding des Viehhalten Impfpass haben.
Genau, weil sonst toll Wut und so.
Mhm. War richtig krass, es ist übrigens wenn du mit einem Pferd über die Grenze fahren willst.
Mhm. So ähm.
Das äh äh musst du quasi äh ja da gibt's so ein bürokratischen Prozess, da musst du es sozusagen anmelden äh beziehungsweise eine Genehmigung äh ähm.
Dafür besorgen. Also du kannst nicht einfach irgendwie ein Pferd einpacken und irgendwohin fahren, sondern.
Oder irgendwo hinreiten.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es beim Reiten äh äh ist. Äh.
Aber egal wir kommen äh hier gerade vom Team ab, aber ja.
So ist das, Mallorca. Und ich hoffe, das wird auch für den Rest Spaniens gelten. Also ich fände einfach mal dieses Vehikel.
Impfen, Urlaub gegen impfen.
Ist eigentlich genau das Richtige meiner Meinung nach. Ne? Also wer jetzt der Meinung ist, müsste nicht geimpft werden. Okay, aber dann bleibst du halt auch in deinem Kaff.
Wenn du dich bewegen willst, weil du irgendwie Lust hast, äh, durch die Welt zu kommen, ja, meinetwegen, aber dann bitte halt einfach impfen.
Also ich sehe überhaupt nicht, was dagegen spricht.
Klar, Härtefälle, Ausnahmen und so weiter kann ich geimpft werden, Pipapo und dann kann man ja immer noch so ein Regime aufsetzen mit irgendwie Test und nochmal Test beim Anflug und Test beim Ankommen und irgendwie was weiß ich, Quarantäne
aber ich meine okay, ich weiß, dass das dann sozusagen den den Freiheitsraum der Leute in dem Moment einschränkt, aber das würde es ja auch sonst, wenn wir die Panemie wieder anfeuern
dann ist es halt für alle scheiße und deswegen muss man da glaube ich einfach solche Maßnahmen ergreifen.
Ja, also es gibt nicht, ich habe gerade den Artikel, den du da verlinkt hast, äh äh mir äh nochmal angesehen.
Und äh ja das ist wohl nur eine große,
kontroverse äh so in verschiedene Länder handhaben, das gerade ganz anders, wohl Rumänien, Polen und Estland zum Beispiel,
da hast du keine Quarantänepflicht, wenn du einen Impfnachweis hast, so.
Und aber Türkei, Frankreich, Kroatien, Österreich, Italien sind hier noch erwähnt, äh, da ist mit äh,
ist egal, ob Impfung oder oder nicht, spielt keine Rolle, du musst äh gilt halt das Gleiche für alle und,
ein Grund, der da auch immer genannt wird, weil noch nicht klar ist, ob geimpfte, nicht doch das Virus weitergeben können. Ähm was da der Stand,
ist der mir bekannt ist, dass es doch deutliche Hinweise darauf.
Dass es auf jeden Fall die Übertragung deutlich reduziert.
Ich glaube aber ähm vermutlich nicht auf null, also äh ich glaube es gibt durchaus auch Fälle äh.
Wo dann doch das Virus weitergegeben werden kann trotz Impfung, aber äh.
Ja, die gibt es. Also ich meine, dass das äh das wird ja nun derzeit auch untersucht. Also man untersucht ja jetzt sozusagen nach der Impfung auch noch weiterhin, ähm wie es sich so verhält. Wir haben ja hier, glaube ich, schon mehrfach auch solche
Beispiele genannt, also moderner hat er schon bei der Zulassung in der EU schon Paper vorgelegt, wo sie solche Zahlen ja äh schon angedeutet haben, die aber einfach noch nicht die
denenswerte Anzahl an Fällen abgedeckt hat. Also man man sieht das schon, aber es ähm,
die Studien sind laufen auch nicht lang genug, um eine ausreichend verlässliche, große,
Basis an Teilnehmern zu haben. Es ist aber eben schon so, dass sich das Abzeichen erstmal sagen kann. Nein, es verhindert nicht.
Allen Fällen Reeffektion, ja? Weil das ist ja auch klar, der Impfstoff,
der nistet sich im Immunsystem ein und in dem Moment wo der Virus auf den Körper übergreifen will, da kriegt er dann seine Barriere vorgeschoben,
aber die Infektion beginnt äh eben durch Eurosohle, die du einatmest und die Replikation,
findet ja in der Nase, im Rachenraum statt und das ist ja das, was dieses Virus so gefährlich macht und ist relativ schnell am Start,
nach zwei, drei Tagen kannst du eben schon wieder eine Infektion haben. Du müsstest halt dein Immunsystem muss eben so gut mit Immunzellen ausgestattet sein, dass es eben auch eine hohe Präsenz,
in diesem Nasen-Rachentrakt hat, um das sozusagen sofort zu bekämpfen. Zu hundert Prozent meine ich. Aber.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass der, dass die Impfung nur eine schwerere Erkrankung verhindert, sondern es heißt halt einfach, das Immunsystem ist auf zack, kaum ist der Virus da, Attacke,
Das kann natürlich dann auch in vielen Fällen dazu führen, dass es dann eben,
dass man nicht so lange infektiös ist, dass man nicht so sehr infektiös ist, bis hin zu eben überhaupt nicht infektiös äh ist. Und das senkt natürlich dann den R,
erheblich. Und das ist ja dann der entscheidende Faktor für alle. Während alle geimpft, würde dieser RWT eben nicht mehr bei
was auch immer, wo wir ihn jetzt gerade einschätzen, je nach Variante äh liegen, sondern eben deutlich niedriger und wäre vielleicht dann natürlich sozusagen schon unter eins und damit stirbt er dann halt auch aus. Selbst wenn sich noch weiter Leute infizieren,
Und da müssen wir halt hin und da sind wir jetzt noch nicht, ist ganz klar. Aber auf der anderen Seite finde ich halt die Ansage, ey impf dich einfach.
Sonst gibt's halt einfach noch keinen Urlaub, weil das bedeutet, dass du die Leute, die du dir importierst,
haben ein erheblich gesenktes Risiko weiter zur Panimie beizutragen.
Ja? Das ist ja schon mal was und mal so ganz nebenbei erzeugst du eben auch einen Druck auf Leute, zu saßen,
Du willst maximale Freiheit haben und du willst ein Easyjet Leben wieder zurückhaben? Ja okay, gut, aber dann müssen wir halt tauschen.
Und der Tausch heißt halt einfach zwei Spritzen und dann ist die Sache auch gegessen. Und wenn du da Angst vor hast.
Dann setze ich halt wieder zu Hause ins Wohnzimmer.
Ich habe mir es auch nicht bekannt, dass es irgendwie großere Debatten je darüber gab äh so.
Dass man halt für bestimmte Länder einfach Impfungen braucht ähm so.
Wir können mich auch nicht erinnern, wenn ich nach Afrika fliege, dann impfe ich mich auch gegen alles mögliche. Ich werde in Französisch-Guyana bin ich nicht reingelassen worden, ohne Geldfieberimpfung. Die hätten mich dann einfach sofort wieder nach Hause geschickt oder gar nicht erst aufs aufs Flugzeug, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann sie es gecheckt haben.
Dass es da einfach die Voraussetzung, weil die einfach nicht wollen, dass äh.
Verstehst gar nicht, welche Seite er das nicht will, aber da da gibt's halt Gelbfieber und das soll dann eben nicht wieder zurückgetragen werden. Und deswegen ist die Impfung einfach vorgeschrieben zum Schutz von mir selbst, aber eben auch zum Schutz der Gemeinschaft.
Da ist jetzt nichts anderes. Gut Pavel, wollen wir was zu Ende bringen? Ich denk,
das äh reicht, haben die zwei Stunden wieder voll gekriegt im Wesentlichen,
Uns bleibt jetzt eigentlich nur äh tschüss zu sagen für diese Woche und wie gesagt, wenn ihr Lust habt, Dienstag, Quatsch mal wieder,
in diesem Clubhausraum, das ist immer sehr nett, kommt auch gerne dazu, wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt.
Ich weiß, ist nicht auf allen Plattformen unterstützt, trotzdem ist der Mehrwert jetzt schon so groß, dass es sich einfach sehr lohnt
das für uns äh zu machen. Wir tragen das Feedback aber auf jeden Fall wieder in diese Sendung mit rein. Von daher
geht da auch nichts verloren und darüber erreichen wir dann einfach auch nochmal ganz neue Kreise von Leuten, die dann sich vielleicht auch noch anschließen, hier diesen Podcast zu hören, was uns natürlich sehr freuen würde.
Ja keinen positiven Ausblick mehr von mir.
Hast jetzt schon alle durch, ja?
Ja gut, also derzeit zahlen, ich kann ja mal die die Zeit nochmal grob deuten, also die Zahlen gehen runter, das ist gut, wir wissen noch nicht so ganz genau,
dieser ähm Weg wieder verlassen wird. Wir finden die Signale, die die Politik nicht im Prinzip falsch, aber noch ist ja nicht alles verloren,
ganze Situation lässt sich ohnehin sehr schwer vorhersagen, wir fahren alle in gewisser Hinsicht auf Sicht. Aber.
So ein bisschen Durchhaltevermögen bist du schon noch mit aufbringen. Also ich denke mal,
bis Ostern wird es auf jeden Fall alles noch sehr beschränkt bleiben müssen,
wie es nach Ostern aussieht, das hängt glaube ich sehr von dieser Variantenverbreitung ab. Es hängt davon ab, wie die Impfkampagne vorankommt. Es hängt davon ab, wie die Impfbereitschaft äh vorankommt,
hängt natürlich auch davon ab, wie die politische Diskussion läuft. Da haben wir nur begrenzten Einfluss drauf. Aber wir haben euch jetzt mal
gesagt, was wir so rausgefunden haben und jetzt könnt ihr ein bisschen drüber nachdenken und wir hören uns dann nächste Woche wieder und sagen tschüs.
Ja, jetzt, ja, jetzt muss ich doch noch.
Jetzt wo ich schon den Abschluss gefunden habe. Dann legt ihr nochmal einen hinterher.
Genau, nee, der der genau der Punkt ist äh so Ostern.
Nur wenn wir das mit dem Logdown hinkriegen, so was die Impfung angeht, kriegen wir ein bisschen Schutz für Alte so,
aber ich glaube so vor Juli, August.
Werden wir bei dem derzeitigen Impftempo muss man sagen oder.
Äh werden die Impfstoffe jetzt keine wesentliche Auswirkung auf die Verbreitung haben, außer.
Bestimmten Gruppen vielleicht. Aber so allgemein halt nicht und ähm ja also.
Das Einzige, was positiv ist, ist, dass die Zahlen offenbar noch fallen, so. Ähm,
aber die Simulation, die ich gesehen habe jetzt mit den neuen Virusvarianten prognostizieren, alle äh so diesen Horroranstieg.
Äh auf bis zu hunderttausendzweihunderttausend Zelle pro Tag äh so, wenn äh.
Nichts passiert und das kann halt wohl sehr schnell gehen. Aber noch sind wir auf dem Weg nach unten.
Aber so in ja ich sag mal in drei vier Wochen ungefähr werden wir an so einem kritischen Punkt sein, wo äh ja sich sich entscheidet äh.
Ob wir äh nochmal in einen äh wirklich richtigen Logdown gehen müssen für nochmal ein, zwei Monate, um die dritte Welle.
Zu brechen. So und ich hoffe ähm also eigentlich würde ich mir wünschen.
Dass es uns gelingt äh.
Die Zahlen jetzt nur noch nach unten äh zu bringen und sobald da zwei oder drei Wochen,
äh irgendwas nach oben äh geht, dass wir dann äh sofort und unverzüglich intervenieren, so wie das Beispiel.
Mit äh was heißt Australien, äh wo man dann halt mal eben einen Fünf-Tage-Log-Down macht.
Aber damit sowas funktioniert, muss man natürlich wirklich weit, weit unten sein und muss wirklich jeden einzelnen Fall,
nachspüren können und wollen und davon sind wir noch so meilenweit entfernt äh äh gerade, dass so meine Befürchtung ist, äh dass wir,
so wie sie viel.
Die politische Landschaft und die gesellschaftliche Stimmung äh äh gerade aussieht, dass wir das nicht lange genug durchhalten, um äh eine große, dritte Welle zu vermeiden.
Ja, aber erstmal so äh besteht noch Hoffnung.
Ja, liebe Politik beweist beweist es doch mal das Gegenteil, beweist es doch mal.
Dass dass wir, dass wir, dass wir falsch liegen, das finde ich aber irgendwie auch mal ganz geil. Das wäre doch mal eine Challenge für euch. Die Coped Challenge, die UKW-Kowi-Challenge.
Jetzt aber wir sagen tschüss, bis nächste Woche, bis bald.
Tschüss.